[Musique]
quoi ou attirer bon jour mesdames et
messieurs bienvenue à la suite de notre
programmation spéciale concernant la
visite du pape françois au canada je
suis brune on savoir andreck de québec
et plus spécifiquement sur les plaines
d'abraham c'est un pour vous situer là
un immense parc qui est au coeur de la
ville de québec c'est là qu'on a convié
les fidèles pour suivre l'ensemble de la
visite papale au cours d'épreuves des
prochains jours parce que il ya dix
écrans géants qui sont installés là
c'est les mains un écran qui étaient
installées pour le festival d'été qui
s'est terminée il ya quelques jours à
peine ici à québec
et puis l'ensemble de la présence du
pape à québec sera diffusée sur ses
écrans et vous le voyez sur les images
il ya quelques centaines de personnes et
qui sont présentes pour l'instant reste
à voir si on arrête des milliers de
personnes tel qu'on l'avait probablement
anticipé donc si on le verra au cours
des prochaines les prochaines heures des
prochains jours parce qu'il ya encore
demain au cours des prochaines minutes
on vous fera vivre cet événement le pape
qui vient tout juste d'arriver à la
citadelle de québec ou encore qui est
sur le point d'y arriver nos collègues
sont en place je prends un instant pour
saluer alain crevier qui est avec nous
encore aujourd'hui bonjour alain notre
infatigable collègue alain crevier non
non ce passé commun c'est vraiment un
moment
extrêmement intéressant j'ai
l'impression d'être là un bon moment
dans les pages d'histoire du canada
c'est pour rien ce qui est arrivé aux
premiers peuples et il ya quelque chose
comme une tentative de guérison ou chez
pas de reconnaissance et je suis très
content de thé et on va le vivre
ensemble on quand on va continuer
d'analysé d'abord les propos du pape et
l'ensemble des non-dits parce qu'on y en
a beaucoup qui l'ont dit dans dans cette
visite leur pays on aura l'occasion avec
nos invités ce soir de voir quel est
l'état de situation au québec parce que
notre système de pensionnat au québec
était un peu différent de ce qu'on vous
a expliqué au cours des derniers jours
dans l'ouest et en ontario je vous ai
parlé de mes collègues qui sont en place
je vous les présente à l'instant marie
pierre mercier qui est elle était du
côté de l'aéroport jean lesage ya
également avec nous alexandre lecteurs
citadelle et camille carpentier qui est
à quelque part pas brillé loin nous
probablement sur le site des plaines
d'abraham allons-y chronologiquement la
lumière le pape lui est arrivé peut-être
même avec quelques minutes d'avancé mais
il ya un peu de retard sur l'ensemble de
l'opération qui était prévue aujourd'hui
le pape qui devait arriver ici à
l'aéroport autour de 15h15 finalement il
est arrivé là atterri vers
14h45 le pape et est sorti de l'avion
sur une plateforme élévatrice sur son
fauteuil roulant à l'arrière de l'avion
parce que vous savez
l'organisation ne veux pas qu'on voit
les papes dans ces transitions
déplacement sur son fauteuil roulant
alors c'est pour ça qu'on le fait sortir
à la l'arrière alors que toute son
équipe elle sort à l'avant et ensuite il
y avait deux scénarios bruno soir les
militaires venaient accueillir le pape
sur le tarmac où il accueillait à lattes
et à l'intérieur de la roue par et c'est
le premier scénario qui s'est produit
c'est celui qui était privilégiée si le
pape était en forme alors on peut
s'imaginer qu'il se porte bien il ya le
premier ministre françois legault qui
était là le grand chef de la nation
huronne wendat tréhin rémy vincent il y
avait aussi le ministre fédéral jean
yves duclos le maire bruno marchand
n'est pas présent on vous en a parlé au
cours des derniers jours le maire a reçu
un résultat positif par la coved 9 alors
c'est sa mère est remplaçante qui
étaient ici pour leur présenter alors
elle l'accueille s'est fait assez
rapidement la petite fiat du peuple
attendait sur le tarmac entouré je dois
dire d'un immense cortège de sécurité le
pape s'est dirigé assez rapidement vers
le centre ville de québec qui vous savez
au cours des derniers mois comme
journaliste comme présidente de la ville
de québec on a vu des policiers
sur les routes en cortège à plusieurs
reprises on se demandait à chaque fois
s'il y avait quelque chose d'urgent qui
se passait et bien non c'est lé est
policier qui se prépare est justement à
cette visite importante les politiques
sont habitués évidemment de suivre des
utilitaires de d'assurer leur sécurité
mais en tout cas sillas ils ne sont ils
ne l'ont jamais fait avec un papa -
qu'il soit très vieux parce que la
dernière fois c'était en 1984 et c'est
une sécurité qui est très importante les
800 agents du spvq sont tous mobilisés
sur le terrain au cours des prochains
jours on a vu un hélicoptère qui suit
également le convoi et les policiers oui
assurent la sécurité du pape mais
doivent assurer aussi la sécurité des
citoyens qui vont être assemblés dans
des foules jerry la foule gérer les
entraves aussi à la circulation et gérer
toute autre urgence qui peut aussi se
produire sur sur le territoire de la
ville de québec alors vous le disiez il
ya des retards malgré que le pape est
arrivé d'avancé que l'avion de ses
invités des grands chefs des nations
autochtones partout au canada et de
certains membres de l'organisation c'est
avions là est porteur et bien sûr ces
gens là doivent être présents à la
citadelle pour l'allocution du pape
alors il faut attendre ces gens là donc
c'est pour ça que c'est retarder un
petit oui on aura l'occasion parlait
avec un journaliste qui lui est à bord
de ses avions et qu'on comprendra
probablement un peu plus ce qui s'est
passé mais ça fait partie de des
imprévus et ça peut arriver dans une
organisation grande comme celle-là marie
pierre mercier on vous retrouvera un peu
plus tard au cours de cette émission là
alors maintenant à l'autre côté de la
route qu'ils avaient à faire le pape et
l'ensemble de son convoi à la citadelles
de québec alexandre disait il ya
quelques minutes que vous avez aperçu
aperçu le pape qui qui arrive elle
assure l'élue mots
je pensais mais c'était le premier
ministre lance canada justin trudeau qui
a aussi beaucoup beaucoup contribué à
son succès autour de lui je suis désolé
c'est ça désolé pour cette fausse alerte
mais il arrive le pape françois et on
nous a dit dans quelques minutes 10 15
minutes ce sera à voir donc à l'avancé
un peu sur l'horaire qui est prévu je
vous montre son premier arrêt où il se
fera oui c'est à la citadelle de québec
où il y aura une petite cérémonie
d'accueil qui est prévu donc comme je le
mentionnais des dignitaires qui sont
arrivés regarder avec moi l'horaire des
prochaines heures pour le pape françois
donc cérémonie d'accueil par la suite à
17 heures ce sera deux rencontres pour
le pas françois à l'intérieur de la
citadelle choix avec la gouverneure
générale marie saimone et par la suite
rencontre avec le premier ministre jeux
du canada justin trudeau et se sont déjà
rencontrés du côté des mountain mais ce
sera le moment prévues à l'horaire on
parle d'une vingtaine de minutes de
chaque pour vraiment discuter des enjeux
de réconciliation le pape françois ce
sera suivie aux antilles 7h45 d'un
disque au fort attendue du père françois
mais également de la gouverneur générale
marie saimone tout ça ça va se dérouler
derrière moi c'est un discours qui est
public qui sera diffusée également sur
les plaines d'abraham un discours très
attendu où on pourrait revoir le pas
françois s'excuser à nouveau pour les
pensionnats autochtones
avec l'homme j'entendais ya quelques
minutes à peine une entrevue avec le
patron de québec cité qui parlait de la
très touristique que peut représenter la
visite du pape par le simple fait que ya
un rayonnement international ya des
dizaines de journalistes de partout dans
le monde qui suivent cette délégation et
qui parle donc de ce voyage et qui parle
du québec et 2 québec un peu partout
dans le monde
c'est majeur il ya des journalistes d'un
peu partout dans le monde ils sont
entourés aussi autour de moi je voulais
montre parce que on était une vingtaine
de journalistes accrédités ici à la
citadelle et l'ail en tout près d'une
cinquantaine qui vient tout juste
d'arriver ce sont les journalistes qui
se promènent pour ce voyage avec le pape
françois pour sa visite au canada dont
qu'ils étaient dans l'avion ils viennent
tout juste d'arriver d'où pourquoi aussi
que le pape françois sera d'ici sera ici
d'une minute à l'autre alors ses
journalistes est là oui ils font
rayonner québec ils font cette
couverture spéciale vous savez aussi
bruno 1 dans les dernières semaines
c'était tout que de la logistique autant
pour nous que beaucoup encore plus pour
des journalistes qui viennent de partout
ailleurs j'ai parlé aux journalistes de
la société suiviez de toronto c'était
quand même une de ses premières
couvertures à québec il dit on
s'attendait à voir des centaines de
milliers de personnes finalement on
pense pas que ça va être le cas mais
quand même c'est important peu importe
d'où on vient finalement du canada de
couvrir cet événement complètement
majeur qui se passe dans notre ville je
vous laisse le temps
voilà le pape françois qui arrivera ici
à la citadelle pour je vous rappelle son
premier arrêt ici à québec c'est dans
quelques minutes à peine je n'arrête pas
de regarder derrière moi parce qu'il ya
des délégations là qui arrivent des
dignitaires on a vu des représentants
les peuples autochtones également comme
je vous rappelle le premier ministre
justin trudeau qui vient tout juste
d'entrer dans la citadelle alors on
suivra ça de très près et on vous fait
signe au moment où le pape françois fait
son premier arrêt alexandre j'allais
vous le dire on ira vous et on ira aux
images surtout d'arriver du patron soit
d'aix kolko je sais qu'il ya des
centaines de personnes sont massées sur
grande allée notamment pour l'accueillir
je suis passé note alors qu'était claude
truc sont installés merci on se dit à
tout à l'heure alexane on tenait à être
sur place ici sur les plaines parce
qu'on savait que c'est là que les
fidèles allait se rassembler pour être
ensemble pour vivre cet événement la
cami vous êtes à travers ses fidèles
juste devant la scène je sais qu'il ya
des représentants de la marche poids
mouche chez eux qui sont sur la scène
présentement donc à travers les gens
travers les fidèles qu'on a convié sur
place
oui ça s'appuie comme vous l'avez dit
bruno à tout à l'heure d'entrée de jeu
il n'y a pas énormément non il ya
quelques centaines de personnes
mais c'est dur a estimé bon la foule
c'est sûr que dans une endroit comme les
plaines d'abraham le voyais autour de
moi c'est vide on est loin de la foule
de milliers de personnes qu'on attendait
ici du moins pour l'instant il ya
peut-être plus de gens nés tous vont
arriver a dit si le discours du pape qui
sera retransmis sur les écrans géants
dans un mois vers 17h30 et vous voyez a
déjà qui ont un jour choisi une place de
choix sur le bord de la route là où va
se déplacer le pape en papamobile vers
18h15 avec sont arrivés assez tôt sur
les plaines d'abraham là quelques
personnes qui en a même une personne
rencontrée ce matin qui a campé sur les
thèmes pour être prêt d'avoir une bonne
place mais au nombre de personnes kial
je vous dirais que même si vous arrivez
à cette heure ci c'est certain que vous
allez avoir une bonne place pour si vous
voulez voir le pape peut se déplacer en
partenaires
et l'ensemble de ce qui va se passer
camille durand tout durant tout le
voyage du pape sera retransmis sur ses
écrans là donc les gens qui peuvent pas
se rendre par exemple à sainte anne de
beaupré pourront assister à tous les
événements sur ses écrans qui sont juste
derrière
oui absolument et en ce moment ce que
vous voyez derrière moi bon vous l'avez
dit ce sont des gens qui prennent la
parole tous les gens avec des chandails
orange ce sont les gens qui font partie
de cette grande marche de guérison de
réconciliation qui a pris le départ de
mashteuiatsh il ya à peu près une
semaine dont qu'ils étaient treize
acquittés match des yankees ont marché
275 kilomètres pour se rendre ici sur
les plaines d'abraham donc bien sûr tout
au long du parcours ya des gens qui se
sont ajoutés qui ont qui ont joint la
marche et sont arrivés ici il ya
quelques temps là vous pouvez voir les
images on était là pour les accueillir
notamment c'est une marche pour honorer
les disparus donc ceux qui ont péri
malheureusement dans les pensionnats une
marche pour honorer surtout les
survivantes et j'ai parlé à jay launière
mathias qui est un des organisateurs de
cette grande marche lui il marchait pour
sakho comme sa grand mère qui est une
survivante d'un pensionnat on va
l'entendre et vous allez ensuite
entendre sa grand mère qui a participé à
quelques segments de la marche
je pensais vraiment beaucoup de fierté
fierté individuelle parce que c'est un
gros défi pour chacun d'entre nous mais
je pense surtout de fiat et collectives
parce qu on le fait tous ensemble ce
parcours leur instinct c'est un travail
d'équipé chaque personne parcourir les
kilomètres qui pouvaient contribuer tant
il est de contrer le marché baisse est
en train de se soutenir emotionnellement
spirituellement vraiment je pensais
c'était à l'image de nos communautés de
nos nations ou qu est ce qui m est sûre
ce sont les invasions sont disponibles
contre j'appuierai ya jamais retourner
chez eux
oui moi aussi quand j'y pense ça aurait
pu m'arriver aussi
puis donc sans fard nos
arrière-petits-enfants
on veut qu'ils soient heureux qu'on soit
libéré aussi que nadal ait le scooter
pour gehrig
donc nous on va rester sur les plaines
cet après midi pour suivre cette
première journée de la visite du pape
dit si il ya des spectacles d'artistes
autochtones qui devrait débuter sous peu
jusqu'à la retransmission du discours du
pape a encore une fois vers 17h30
merci beaucoup cas mais je veux revenir
avoue alain quelques instants avant
qu'on parle de la spécificité du québec
dans tout ce scandale des pensionnats
autochtones dommage pour ce qui nous
saute aux yeux il ya beaucoup moins de
monde que ce qu'on attendait c'est vrai
c'est vrai ça soulève des questions sont
intéressants en temps on a dit à un
moment donné c'est l'art autochtone
c'est le moment autochtone et moi je
trouvais cela un peu chacun n'entendait
pas je me dis on comprend que tout est
sur la question qui touche les
autochtones mais il faudra pas que ça
devienne quelque chose du genre samcon
sambo
vous lisez quand vous regardez cette
offre ouais je me demande est ce qu'on a
ce qu'on a est-ce qu'on a développés est
ce qu'on a provoqué sa maman gâteau
c'est l'automne c'est pas la mienne ça
ne concerne pas ce qui s'est passé n'est
pas ça me concerne pas et ce serait
profondément chacun que ce soit ça parce
que il ya c'est d'abord et avant tout un
phénomène de société c'est un
gouvernement qui au 19e siècle a
provoqué ça et ensuite ça cesse a duré
des décennies lancé dans là je sais pas
ce que c'est ça à ce que c'est aussi on
pourrait y voir quelque chose de
absolument spectaculaire c'est qu'en
1984 quand jean paul ii est arrivé à
québec ce délire total on pensait pas
que ce serait si fort ça a été des
livres à partir du moment où il sort de
l'avion jusqu'à l'aube ou du pays mais
était il ya 40 ans il ya depuis 40 ans
la société a tellement changé je vois
c'est évident la quantité de québécois
et de canadiens mais surtout les
québécois particulièrement qui ont
décroché et complète entrepris une sorte
de pèlerinage spirituel qui ne plus rien
avoir avec les listes a peut-être qu'il
se sent pas ni interpellé ni par
l'institution parce que c'est le papier
ni par cet homme qui je pense des
sincères et qui est authentique alors il
ya en plus de ça ce qui est ce qui est
troublant quand on regarde ça là c'est
qu'on dit que c'est une page d'histoire
s'est pas c'est pas banal alors que ce
soit suffisant ou pas les halls et les
excuses du pape
c'est pas sympa que seul c'est le fait
que on constate on essaie de reconnaître
quelque chose qui est une erreur
monumentale dans notre histoire
et si je me dis c'est difficile à
imaginer que ça a été réceptionné map à
personne et souhaitant que de ses deux
arrières il ya foule on va on va venir
tantôt avec vous sur ce qui s'est dit
pour ce qui s'est passé dans l'ouest la
demande de pardon du pape pie ix on
s'attend à ce que le même scénario soit
répétée si demande de pardon des excuses
mais et on veut le voir avec notre
prochain éviter la situation est
peut-être un peu différente ici je suis
avec médéric si oui les historiens
consultant en histoire des premières
nations de la première nation
abitibiwinni
d'origine le wendat je suis bon soin
bonjour ou en fin de journée on va y
aller pour voir jean sioui
tandis qu'ici les pensionnats se sont
développés un peu plus tard que ce qu'on
a vu dans l'ouest on parlait de céder
sur une centaine d'années alors que
c'est plus concentrés dans l'histoire
ici oui tout à fait il faut comprendre
aussi que les pensions pas travailler
seuls ya aussi les écoles de jour comme
c'était le cas par exemple au rwanda qui
une école de jours lantin pour ce qui
est dépensé à noeux il faut aussi
comprendre que certains pensaient
certainement les relations qui ont été
envoyés dans des français en ontario
dans la première moitié du 20e siècle
mais c'est vrai que la majeure partie de
l'histoire des pensionnats au canada se
déroule après la deuxième guerre
mondiale donc j'ai vu qu'on reconstruit
les principaux vent sert les caprices ou
quoi qu'il y en avait eu deux avants
lafond georges mais ensuite après la
deuxième violent de 1953 à 1963 on va
créer les quatre principaux passé c'est
ce qu'ils quitteraient questionnaire est
aberrant à mon sens parce que le système
perdait déjà de justesse dans l'ouest il
y avait déjà eu beaucoup de rapports sur
notamment les mauvaises conditions de
vie socio sanitaire depuis longtemps
donc de construire des patients alors
manqué le canada tous avant d'être
champion des droits de l'homme un
cofondateur de l'onu quand ils génocide
ecce terra se retrouve à construire des
pensionnats
flambant neuf et à les opérer une
vitesse effrénée c'est ce qui est
incroyable alors que même onu dans les
années 60
les années 60 ben oui il ya des si c'est
les piscines la
télévision couleur c'est les belles
voitures et vous comprenez que c'est ça
sa frappe c'est sûr que ces tests est
aussi père au début du siècle mais le
contraste est encore plus frappant est
entre les écoles qui était fréquenté par
le haut les blancs la population
générale et les l'extérieur où les
pensionnats autochtones il y avait comme
on était à vitesse variable il va de 2,2
qualité puis même
deux façons même d'amener l'enseignement
le ce qu'il faut se rappeler à quoi
étaient destinés les pensionnats c'était
à la simulation puis à la destruction
des cultures et des rentes des
programmations des inuit donc oui on
apprenait à les plus difficiles début du
film on apprenait à lire et écrire mais
il y avait
cursus pasteur religieux très très
important donc qui contribua pas
nécessairement à une qualité d'éducation
pour pour l'avenir votre travail c'est
d'étudier l'histoire et de ses effets
probables sur le monde d'aujourd'hui
vous aurez quels sont les effets sur la
nation huronne wendat ici qu'on connaît
bien dans la région qui évoquent et les
autres nations autochtones au québec
quels sont les effets de ces années de
pensionnat
de façon généralisée les pensées ceux
qui ont des effets importants
dès des traumatismes s'écouter imaginez
vous laisser il faut pas juste penser
aux enfants c'est sûr que les enfants
mais il ya eu des parents et enfants et
les grands parents de ces enfants qui
ont subi des chocs importants de perdre
leur enfant se faire enlever leurs
enfants que les générations qui suivent
ensuite
c'est sûr qu'ils aient toutes les
questions des abus que c'est bien connu
mais il faut comprendre aussi toutes les
effets sur la culture sur les traditions
sont nos savoirs sur les pratiques
traditionnelles ce site si d'ici là
rattraper faut lier des efforts qui sont
au niveau des armes et caetera mais
c'est beaucoup de travail on en a encore
pour beaucoup d'années juste 4 ap un peu
jeu c'est dommage je cite ces jeunes
gens
votre connaissance de la langue à quel
niveau vous
pas très élevée chez les gens on a un
programme de taureaux vitalisation
rwanda qui donc on participe mais je
suis je connais plusieurs personnes
m'ont dit qu'ils me disent ça se limite
à crouy malheureusement
le moment qu'on vit aujourd'hui va
passer à l'histoire dont par
l'importance par le fait qu'il ya quand
même le chef de l'église catholique qui
à l'invitation des premières nations est
venu ici pour s'excuser donc juste pour
soi ça passera à l'histoire mais qu'est
ce qu'on retiendra de ce qu'est ce que
ça va changer dans l'avenir
mais pas le pour l'instant ce qu'on
retiendra c'est qu'ils y répéter les
mêmes choses les mêmes paroles que dit
le 1er avril ce qui re plus loin demain
peut-être à s'étendre ce serait une
belle occasion on verra
maintenant ensuite comme ça a été
beaucoup du bain mois un niveau
historique c'est sûr que
je m'attendrais ce que des actions
suivent ces paroles l'appui ces actions
le ce serait de
couvrir l'ensemble des archers mais non
seulement l'ouvrir mais de t d a guidé
dans ses archives que c'est si compliqué
dans des archives c'est que il ya des
sens c'est pas commun qui sont organisés
leurs archives de la chef donc de
collaborer à ses recherches le et non
seulement ceux de force également les
basco des fluence et positivement les
ordres religieux tels que les oblats
remake les conceptions à faire de même
et de travailler de bonne foi répondre
aux questions des gens qui ont perdu un
proche atteint et qui ont jamais eu de
réponse à travers le système des
pensionnats c'est ce qui importe et
dernier point je fais partie de la
génération puis je pense que bien des
gens vont se reconnaître lada ce drame
l'eau des pensionnats autochtones je
n'ai pas appris à l'école on nous pond a
saigné sont dans l'histoire faudra
revoir nous
effectivement dans l'est la dernière
réforme on a réussi j'étais sur le
comité on a réussi à faire a ajouté un
point complet sur les pensionnats mais
c'est il ya manque encore il faut que ça
soit elle une place de choix et qu'elle
soit il ya aussi
véhiculée par l'ensemble du réseau
scolaire c'est très important et
probablement adaptée mais lily et de
l'ajouter dans l'es10 échangés oui
voudraient que si oui merci beaucoup de
votre passage je vous laisse aller pour
le mieux vivre avec certains de vos amis
ici ce qu'on arrive sur les plaines
d'abraham mais surtout de votre passage
pour apple il est historien consultant
en histoire des premières rade nation il
ya eu un retard dans l'horaire du jour
parce qu'il ya eu un problème de gestion
d'avions aux heats comprendre un peu
avec lou baissement de senneville il est
correspondant ont fait au vatican pour
le journal la croix monsieur bêtement de
sendai pour jour
voilà vous êtes ou physiquement et vous
étiez dans quel avion
alors physiquement là je suis à la
citadelle enfin de pile en face de
l'entrée de du gouverneur général et
j'étais dans l'avion du pape donc fait
l'avion qui est arrivé à l'heure mais il
ya un deuxième avion qui a une heure de
retard a donc fait pour ça que tout a
pris du retard aujourd'hui
monsieur paiement de senneville j'ai lu
votre article sur le passage du pape au
sanctuaire sainte anne hier en alberta
comment vous l'interprétez mon collègue
alain crevier juste à côté de moi disait
tout à l'heure cette image du pape qui
se recueille sur les le bord des eaux
sacrées de ce lac vaut faire le tour du
monde de votre point de vue qu'est ce
que ça signifiait ce moment là en
particulier
et pour le pape les gestes qu'on en fait
pratiquement autant que la parole donc
en fait c'était la version gestes de ses
excuses qu'il avait formulées la veille
c'était important pour le pape de venir
dans un lieu
sacré dans un lieu qui était cher aux
autochtones dans 20 lieux aussi des
chères aux autochtones qui sont aussi
catholique donc voila c'était une
manière pour le pape de
dire qu'il avait
compris en tout cas qu'il suçait à la
douleur des survivants et donc c était
une manière pour le pape françois sans
doute de demander pardon à nouveau dans
ce lieu très spécial très particulier
pour ceux à qu une demandait pardon en
réalité
dernier point parce que je peux avoir
votre interprétation vu de l'extérieur
ici on a entendu beaucoup de pas
beaucoup parce que certaines personnes
qui soulignait le fait que le pape ne
prenez pas la responsabilité pour
l'église des cv s'il a demandé pardon à
dieu il a demandé pardon que certains
membres de cette église vous posez des
cv ça des enfants d'automne mais n'a pas
pris la responsabilité au nom de
l'église est sûre vous l'avez pas
nécessairement souligné dans votre texte
parce que vous le ressentez pas vous
n'avez pas entendu cette critique de la
part de certains représentants des
premières nations
alors gelée soulignait dans l'article
d'après chiot à bout mais
il vient de publier deux jours un bémol
au texte
effectivement
il n'a pas endossé la responsabilité
institutionnelle de l'église catholique
et voilà on voit bien aujourd'hui la
déception d'une partie des responsables
autochtones en même temps il me semble
que dans ses discours depuis le début du
voyage une pale quand même alors non
seulement de la responsabilité de
certains catholiques et techno mais il
parle aussi de
d'une mentalité colonisatrice il parle
aussi d'une resto l'unité de plus large
des responsables religieux donc me sens
que la remise en cause qu'opère le pape
est plus large que celle de quelques
individus
de au sein d'églises cas de victoire et
quand il parle de mentalité colonialiste
de mentalité coloniale il me semble que
son propos est plus large mais
effectivement il n'a pas employé le mot
systémique où il n'a pas employé le mot
institutionnels pour incliner tous élus
de cette liste
loubet monde de senneville merci
beaucoup d'avoir appris que j'imagine
que vous avez un horaire chargé on
continuera de vous lire dans la croix
merci bon séjour à québec
merci à vous
alain crevier je vais vous entendre sur
ce que nous venons de nous dire c'est
effectivement je t'avais dit non dit
tout à l'heure il ya un peu de ça
également quatre portes de cet esprit
colonialiste il inclut son église là
dedans dit nous avons aussi fait un seul
mais c'est ainsi et beaucoup de nuances
comme par exemple hier au lac sainte
anne dans l'homélie qu'il a prononcée un
moment donné c'est passé passé inaperçu
c'est dommage r mais c'est humain
françois ça oui dit il va bien falloir
un moment donné se tourner et faire
autre chose que excusez l'institution
ait commencé à chercher la vérité alors
si vous voulez dire quelque chose ne
peut plus précis s'arrêter apprécié mais
ce qui est en train de faire est en
train de montrer certaines autres ce
qu'il qualifie d'anti litres est capable
de dire il dit souvent il a dit souvent
il faut un moment donné arrêté de
défendre à tout prix l'institution mais
de laquelle vous parlez là il parle du
vatican saint-siège temps de l'église et
je pense que là il touche à quelque
chose dans son homélie dans sa première
excuse qui a prononcé au moment de la
messe sur les
animateurs et sur les lieux du
passionnant moi j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait aucun date des papes avait été
aussi loin et je suis pas étonné que les
gens n'aient qu'ils soient pas
satisfaits ma méthode c'est je regardais
je suis pas mal et au tchad le chef est
charles qui était kahn était tremblante
satisfait très content alliant naoto kan
pleurait il y en a d'autres qui étaient
furieux maroc je pense que c'est juste
très piquant que tu t'es fait raison
rendu là là c'est à chacun d'apprécier
ce qui a été fait c'est à chacun
d'exiger gaye plus qu'il soit fait
l'essai vraiment c'est un drame c'est un
long c'est une longue tragédie mais
sélectif mais vécu un chacun va décider
comment il perçoit je voulais surtout
vous dire c'est qu'il y allait y aller
mouiller à tous sauf si je suis
entièrement d'accord c'est important
mais je pense qu est ce qui fait
l'histoire c'est que les premières
nations ont une culot des héros pape
vous allez venir au canada vous excuser
oui je dis toujours on fait face à un
chef d'état ça se fait pas allez vous
appelez joba des pourris vient de
s'excuser monstre postera bon il a fait
ça et il est venu et je pense que c'est
le ski marx qui marque les imaginait ce
qui est très fort dans les images c'est
sa présence sur les lieux c'est
suffisant
ça chacun d'apprécier mais c'est ça le
moment particulier prochains invités on
le connaît bien tous les deux corps est
si oui ancien grand chef de la nation
huronne wendat pueblo
comment c'est la première question je
veux poser
avant de parler à l'ancien grand chef je
veux parler aux hurons wendat très
entendu de demande de pardon du pape qui
ont 17 ans tous avec alain que chacun le
prends personnellement vous comment vous
l'avez vu avec beaucoup de satisfaction
avec beaucoup d'espoir c'est un message
qui est traître est là et je me réfère
aussi à mes frères et soeurs côté de
l'ouest qui ont applaudi le message bien
sûr on n'acceptera pas juste des excuses
suite logique aussi est il ouvert les
archives i love a une capacité de faire
nos recherches plus de découvrir des
vérités parce que c'est important ça
fait partie de la guérison aussi aimé a
maintenant et ce matin ce qui ouvre vers
le développement va l'ouvrir les
territoires puis nous permettre
d'accéder aussi un développement
économique terrain oui culturelle et
spirituelle mais il connaît mes courses
parce que l'église au la clé d'un
certain développement économique lui on
n'a pas besoin de regarder bien loin ici
de l'étape séminaires
et
voilà parce que ça fait partie de la
stratégie du fameux terra nullius dont
on a beaucoup parlé
benoît françois de laval j'aimerais
savoir si des mois la série s'est dit
ici j'aimerais savoir les citera aussi
alors s'est fait déposséder directement
un puits aujourd'hui on arrive devant
ces territoires l'offre une grosse
barrière qui n'ouvre que nous qui nous
ferment toutes possibilités de
partenariat ce spectateur mais à ce que
ça se fait parce que si tu imagines
avant hier mais le sait ce qu est ce que
le pape pourrait par exemple à ondres à
waimes ces points de chefs des
communautés religieuses doivent quand
même c'est le chef de lévis à ce qui
pourrait à des jeux quatre pouces et les
communautés à résoudre cette question là
qu'on voit ici l'establishment des yeux
celle des différents diocèses la france
et aussi de la part du clergé de faire
la place aussi parce que ça sort en
votre nom veut pas devenir des victimes
de notre ville on veut pas être atteints
flurry pleurnicher tout le temps on va
être capable de vivre notre
autodétermination de l'hadopi puisse se
développer comme nation sur une base
d'égalité simplement on échoué d'un
charlatan ont échoué dans meech on doit
pas donner une place si encore du père
fondateur français entre les deux heures
de gloire à main
une aubaine pour toujours aller à la
cour vous savez la cyclassics des
billets pourrait se présenter à la cour
d'assises oui on a passé dix ans à la
cour georges picot stream je souhaite
pas sa personne parce que c'est long et
ardu que c'est coûteux et c'est
peut-être ça le message qui pourrait
être pas assez puissant on va on va être
très attentif au message sera passé aux
évêques domaine lorsque le pape
s'adressera je regarde du coin de l'oeil
il est censé arriver dans les prochaines
secondes donc il est possible qu'on
aille vivre ce moment là ensemble
konrad sioui je pense que c'était notre
première entrevue est très très très
longtemps et on se disait dans cette
entrevue lock on se connaissait mal les
blancs et les premières nations vol est
ce que dans tout le drame qu'on décrit
depuis quelques jours et depuis la
découverte des 80's que dans ce grand
drame là sans repos au moins permis se
connaissent mieux je suis un survivant
des écoles de jour la première
fois à l'école à l'âge de 6 ans quand on
est rentré en jeu à dit à genoux et a
pris un quart seulement des dix gouttes
d'eau bénite que nos ancêtres étaient
des barbares des sauvages et qu'ils
avaient suis dit 'tiens marché canadien
qu'on n'ira pas dans le même ciel que
les autres on irait dans un ciel parce
que tu aimes bien connu mais on n'arrête
jamais ce prix là on est commotion et
ironie tic on est dit on veut inculquer
ce important pour le demande à nos
parents notre part avoir ce qu'il dit
mais il atteint jeudi garder à l'école
un jour on veut écrire notre histoire un
jour on veut que notre version de
l'histoire est différente il a alors la
pelouse parce que on est ensemble
aujourd'hui
puis j'en garde choisi j'ai passé une
grande partie de ma vie à défendre nos
droits mais aujourd'hui je suis
extrêmement positif vis-à-vis ce qui
s'en vient parce que c'est un événement
où aujourd'hui le cirque s'est agrandie
avant cela tout seul aujourd'hui le on
allie années que vit on le dit bruno on
est beaucoup beaucoup de monde qui sont
conscients des situations l'eau puis
ensemble robinson va définir un monde
meilleur puis on va grossir parce que
s'ils cercle quic en jeu j'en profite
encore pendant que le pape n'est pas
encore arrivé parce qu'être que je veux
vous demander la religion catholique on
vous a imposé est venu changer
complètement la dynamique sociétale du
populo wendat la femme a pris beaucoup
coinçant s'était même mis de côté les
clans familiaux ont changé mais de la
femme disparue de la femme notre dieu
ses attentes x et une femme tu es à ton
appris qu'on a toujours prier on est des
sociétés mathy centristes on est nommée
par les femmes les mères de clans comme
grands chefs comme chef jean faire pour
le travail les femmes vont scruter alors
c'était difficile pour nous d'accepter
quoi dieu qui dorénavant ne soit plus
notre belle création label authentique
alors oui on en a souffert de ces choses
là mais on s'est adapté parce que c'est
vous gardez les servir j'ai fait partout
dans les amériques aussi on les aviez
en la mairie viennent en première nation
puis aussi dont cfm un mode de vie une
vie en gardant des parties des parties
de la culture mais risque le
colonialisme loi sur les indiens
auraient un impact aussi négatif
quand on a vu la coiffe être installé
puis allez l'aborder plus tard sur la
tête du pape oui moi je
vous commencez un grand chef comment
vous l'avez chez qui c'est sa peau parce
sinon comme on aime et qui compte phil
fontaine époux
ou étant dit le tchad
il le fait moi je repense à ce que je me
suis dit c'est injuste quand même si
jusqu'à ces faits importants parce que
il a accepté la coiffe ouais il le
portait ya eu une longue discussion
alors il se sent on c'est un grand chef
honoraire des premières nations et y est
à l'oeuvre pour nous avec nous moi je
pense que vous avez raison parce que je
me dis c'est à ce moment précis quand
j'ai vu les deux chaînes s'approcher
avec la cause mais aussi aux non il faut
pas faire ça c'est un moment où ça
aurait pu mal tourner il y aurait
actuellement je sais pas trop serré
manière écouter aurait pu prendre la
coiffe qui allait l'emporter dans une
carotte et tout aurait terminé mais des
sourires se gêner oui cette image que
vous voyez là pour eux et elles vont
rester dans l'histoire sochaux c'est
vous avez le chef de l'église de rome
qui porte la croix d'hins 15 l'apport
des premières nations et au nom du monde
entier publieront pas non plus la
chanteuse cris ouais d'aucuns avancent
qu'ils ôtent chez pizza fait comprendre
la peine la misère la difficulté d'un
dans son chef dans son expression un
second bras savez-vous quoi j'ai passé
la main j'espère ensuite très personnes
jusqu'à pas de façade et fois mais sur
le coup j'étais saisis parce que je
voyais oui je mettais les discordances
de l'hymne national
m'apparaissait comme tout à fait exact
puisque elle dit au pape que je n'ai pas
compris par la suite m'apparaissait
comme un cri fondamental ce cas et j'ai
pas pu faire autrement que de penser à
jimi hendrix qui joue les nationales des
états unis mais à la déchirante houbart
côté un noir tout fricoter je me suis
dit est ce que j'ai un destin me manquer
de cet endroit là un moment où exception
exceptionnel c'est exceptionnel ici on
avait pu la chaussée 05 il y plein mais
eux ils nous le qui de par ici aussi
monsieur et réduire c'est que le dip
dans le fond d'eux y prenez soin de nous
en connaissons nos enfants
prenez soin de 2,2 vous vous repentez
puis aujourd'hui mais c'est un jour
meilleur puis je vous remercie d'être là
et - je chante au canada parce que c'est
mon canada
mais on ne tousse récente si c'est du
lard ouais la peine non et moi la
première c'est
la mode rush sitôt l'annoncé là et c'est
une femme qui le fait oui parce que nos
femmes nos fins mais on a toujours mis
nos femmes très très très très haut dans
lequel se mais je veux pas être méchant
mais les cultures et aux centristes ont
soumis les femmes beaucoup plus beaux
pieds à terre un peu puis paul doit de
se marier ou avec des prêtres quoi que
ce soit ça fait que c'est un excellent
sait très bien que si oui nous recevrait
à peu près une minute avant que le pape
arrive aux attentes est ce que vous
attendez d'autres excuses du pape weezy
spécifiquement les fondations projet des
excuses mais je m'attends à ce qu'on
ouvre sur le territoire je me sens qu'on
est ce que le pape continue son exposé
et demain on va être aux premières loges
on va attendre on va voir on va surtout
vouloir s'assurer que la suite logique
c'est le développement la possibilité
d'un partenariat équitable au camp afin
opus avoir une chance de 2 d'avancé dans
la vie mais pas toujours courbé le dos
et se détend les victimes mais bel et
bien des guerriers qui vise de retrouver
terminé 7ème ferme un talent j'ai comme
l'impression on n'en parle pas mais il
ya une gradation dans l'eure dans les
gestes dans la passe qui est dit dans sa
présence a commencé peut-être ce soir ça
a été quelque part en la matière on
reconnaît que quelque chose l'a ensuite
ya eu de son premier homélie où il est
pardon puis ensuite il ya eu hier au lac
où là c'est pour moi c'est un moment
spire de ruelles c'était vraiment seul
mais là il est ici demain je passais
s'il
ya un crescendo à messieurs les
cardinaux qui s'amène à la citadelle g14
canadien aura quatre canadiens mais il y
en a un dans le lot qui va se soucier
des autres ces piétons par l'insee le
cardinal secrétaire d'état
deux du vatican le chef s'est fermement
en fait c'est que je vous dirai si vous
regardez hormis la question de la
religion 6 tc numéro deux du vatican y
emménagent vraiment l'âge entre autres
des affaires générales de secrétariat
qui concerne tous les devises mais aussi
toutes les questions internationales les
relations avec les états alors on dit
toujours le pape va rencontrer la
gouvernance générale vont rencontrer le
premier ministre lui aussi ok moi ce que
je me suis pas trop de misère à imaginer
qu est ce que le pavot dira trudeau j'ai
pas trop bizarre j'aimerais bien savoir
ce que on va dire un pied trop à pierrot
symboliser la diplomatie oui c'est lui
c'est lui qui fait la police et l'homme
était recherché ce matin est ce qu il
veut juste dire des choses de diplomates
bonjour comme un télégramme je m'appelle
parole une impasse et que on parle des
messages politiques c'est parti c'est le
genre de personnage dont on parle le
plus sauf succincte et raisonnements la
question de les discuter je vais pas
tourner et faire danser grand chef sioui
mais tout à l'heure c'est votre
successeur qui accueillent ils peuplent
les vives à ce que vous aviez s'y
exprimer et j'avais droit d'autrui c'est
très bien
pascal enfin on fait un bout de chemin
j'ai remplacé marc meilleur un modèle il
faudrait construire parle de la justice
parce que j'ai comme l'impression en
attendant on veut pas être des victimes
tout le temps de faire autre chose on
est des guerriers qui on revient il ya
quelque chose de lob de quelque chose
qui nous échappe et qui est tellement je
pense la clé de notre relation est foutu
et il savait quoi vont revenir konrad
sioui de nos émissions au cours des deux
prochains jours vous laissent leur a dit
oui merci beaucoup c'est un plaisir
laisse aller vivre avec un veau collex
on va vivre ensemble l'arrivée du pape
françois qui s'amène à la citadelle
c'est la résidence officielle de la
gouverneure générale à québec allons-y
[Musique]
c'est le gouverneur général du sevn qui
sort à l'extérieur il est accompagné du
premier ministre notamment
et c'est à ce moment là que se passe
l'accueil officiel vont ces gens notions
déjà rencontrés depuis le début de ce
voyage du pape mais on le fait de façon
plus protocolaire à la résidence des
gouvernants générale lâche le chic pour
rappeler qu'il ya un certain temps de
sun notre premier ministre ok ce moment
estimé le pape à venir au canada doit
s'excuser ce n'est pas comme juste et le
geste diplomatiquement très souhaitable
on a un gros poisson souvent et je n'ai
pas vu un pape a accepté une telle chose
alors je sais pas s'ils se diront
quelque chose à propos de ça mais il y
avait un geste très audacieux de la part
du produit de plus audacieux des
informations de m le niveau geste reste
au dessus de la part du problème liste
destinée aux chefs de lévis de venir ici
s'excuser mais il attendait les autres
oui
vous l'avez bien dit c'est au cours des
derniers jours alors cette cérémonie
très protocolaire effet sous haute
surveillance de l'occasion d'en discuter
avec marcel savard il est ex directeur
adjoint à la sûreté du québec on a
souvent discuté avec monsieur savoir au
cours des derniers jours concernant les
sécurités bonjour monsieur savard
bonjour
monsieur savoir je sais pas si vous avez
eu accès aux images aériennes on voit
différents véhicules plusieurs noir est
la plus sobre de tout c'est la fiat
blanche du pape décrivez-nous qui est
dans ces véhicules là et quels types de
sécurité on a actuellement bas
évidemment on ne peut se permettre
d'être
être laxiste sur la sécurité donc à
naves à l'avant et à l'arrière du
véhicule pas on a des véhicules qui
contiennent d'abord probablement est
certainement ses gardes du corps
rapprocher et par la suite on a des
véhicules qui vont être des véhicules de
soutien on a vu le long du trajet sur
grande allée un peu plus tôt qu'il avait
deux ambulances donc des ambulances qui
ont des équipements particuliers qui
sont capables d'offrir
des soins supplémentaires si arrivé
quelque chose par la suite ont
évidemment des groove et us noir les
vitres teintées ce sont des équipes
spécialisées et à la limite dans les
ventes par ce que je vois une vanne est
de 2,2 va naître ça ce sont certainement
des équipes tactiques sont à l'intérieur
ou des équipements de captation des
ondes que ce soit les ombres parler ou
des ondes qui pourraient être émises par
ce que l'objectif est évidemment
d'empêcher toute émission d'une onde qui
pourrait provoquer la déflagration d'un
objet d'étonnant donc ce sont des
équipements et du personnel hautement
spécialisés qui sont là ils sont
discrets mais évidemment aujourd'hui
avec
les médias on peut très bien imaginer
que les équipes spécialisées à
l'intérieur sont prêts à intervenir si
avec quelque chose moi ce qui
m'interpelle
c'est vraiment l'aspect de gouvernance
actuellement vous savez la citadelle de
québec c'est la maison-mère du royal 22e
régiment est déjà là on va être
enterrée militaire si vous me permettez
l'expression est déjà là il doit y avoir
une coordination
des efforts de sécurité à l'intérieur de
la bâtisse avec la grc parce que ça soit
la grc est évidemment la défense
nationale donc il ya une coordination
qui fait quoi qui est responsable de
quoi à l'extérieur de ce terrain la grc
offre évidemment la coordination
générale de les vêtements et les autres
services policiers viennent s'occuper
d'un parti de
responsabilité
exemple lorsqu'on était en sera demain
sur le trajet d'air sainte anne de
beaupré la sûreté du québec et la ville
de québec sera certainement mise à
profit dans les scop du convoi donc
est-ce qu'on voit actuellement là c'est
vraiment des équipes spécialisées des
personnes responsables de la sécurité du
pape qu'ils sont lors qu'ils en espèrent
elles n'auront pas été bonne et on
essaie d'être le plus discret possible
c'est l'objectif qu'on veut c'est
justement pour ça qu'il ya autant de
sécurité c'est con on veut que tout se
passe bien monsieur savard vous restez
là parce que là on va assister ensemble
à l'arrivée officielle du pape c'est
allons entendre et
particularités vous mesurez le pape
n'est pas assis dans le siège arrière
des noms circulent passage très remarqué
et est ouvert tout fait rater il salue
légende malheureusement on n'a pas pu
voir les images tout à l'air de ce qu'on
voit là entre un l'aéroport
international jean lesage et son arrivée
à la citadelle mais la frite est ouverte
effectivement puis le pape salue les
gens au passage donc je vous le rappelle
c'est l'accueil officiel dans quelques
minutes on me dit à 16h40 donc le pape
va prononcer un discours de même que la
gouverneure générale occasion
gérald cyprien lacroix vous avez
remarqué la belle poignée de main
chaleureuse lors de l'arrivée du pape
pie mountain a fait remarquer avec
gérald cyprien lacroix ce sont deux
jeunes suspects je suis pas si on peut
parler d'une grande amitié personnelle
mais se connaît très très bien ouais et
pour la petite histoire le cardinal
lacroix subi une opération il ya deux ou
trois ans est une des premières
personnes qu'il a téléphoné après son
opération c'était le pape
lacroix m'a raconté que l'infirmière
n'était pas en accord avec le fait qu'il
ait une conversation téléphonique alors
qu'il sortait à peine de l'anesthésique
et convenant lacroix me disais bon
c'était embêtant à dire au pape que je
vous rappelle un peu plus tard
je vous signale au passage que sur les
plaines d'abraham ont diffusé ces images
là en direct et olivier avec vous et on
a entendu des applaudissements le dec le
pape est arrivé sur son fauteuil alors
allons-y
donc le battle
aussi
[Musique]
où
je
petit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'hymne national canadien qu'on a
entendu et juste avant à l'est l'hymne
national sur fatick oui jusqu'au 2
septembre michael moore et d'ignorance
malheureuse connaissais pas mais nous
avons des ressources sur le plateau très
content plus qu'ils ont permis de le
confirmer
donc c'est peut-être pour ça que vous
avez peut-être reconnu immédiatement ses
terres
donc ça fait partie d'accueil officielle
du pape françois qui va s'amener
probablement l'intérieur
de la résidence de la gouverneure
générale pour la présentation de
discours
qui sera retransmis sur les plaines
d'abraham
je sais pas si marcel savard est
d'accord avec nous
je savoir je veux juste avoir votre
point de vue sur ce qui s'en vient et un
peu plus tard le père françois qui va
venir sur les plaines avec la papamobile
à la rencontre des centaines de fidèles
qui sont là pour lui est ce que c'est un
enjeu de sécurité important alors que ya
pas eu de coup de folie nécessairement y
avait pas besoin de laisser passer pour
rentrer ici sur le site donc est-ce que
ça a même un enjeu de sécurité plus
important bah ils ont été beaucoup plus
difficile pour les autorités les gens
qui sont responsables de la sécurité
s'il y avait eu une masse très important
de gens parce que ça devient extrêmement
difficile de voir même si on a un angle
de vision puis des gens dans la foule
qui prennent la peine de regarder de
cibler des personnes qui auraient un
comportement inhabituel
quand on a une foule très compacte ça
devient très difficile de cibler plus
loin qu'un disque a inscrit 20 pieds ou
4,5 m si vous voulez ça devient tout un
art alors que là on aura quand même une
folle qui est minimale pas beaucoup de
personnes donc si chacun des policiers
d'abord qui seront sur les lieux
visibles et aussi les politiques sont en
civil ça devient beaucoup plus facile
pour eux de cibler dans un angle de
vision que chacun se partage parce c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne de voir s'il
ya des gens avec des comportements
inhabituels ou à risque ce que je vois
moi je voudrais juste rajouter ce site
impôts au moment de l'arrivée officielle
pa je suis très heureux de voir qu'on
est capable d'adapter les mesures de
sécurité on a à peine vu un garde du
corps rapprocher lorsque la caméra et un
certain angle il était assez loin mais
il faut considérer que cet environnement
de la citadelle et sécuriser
complètement
scellé planification québec ben oui
c'est ça et il aurait été facile dans
d'autres circonstances d'autres chefs
d'état de vraiment rendre parce que des
fois c'est ce qu'on veut on veut rendre
visible à toutes les mesures de sécurité
et dans le cas présent ben je suis
content je suis heureux de voir que on a
adapté sa et le garde du corps était à
s'éloigner il faisait son rôle il
regardait ailleurs que le pape parce que
c'est la technique c'est pas la menace
viendra voir du parfumeur vaut mieux
d'ailleurs donc il n'était concentrer
sur leurs regards sur vraiment
l'extérieur ce qui pourrait empirer
thierry du pape mais très éloigné et
c'est rassurant donc on est quand même
capable d'adapter les mesures de
sécurité contenu en plus que c'est la
citadelle de québec ouais en plus et
marcel savard merci beaucoup de votre
éclairage on aura certainement besoin de
votre votre expertise un peu plus tard
au cours de nos émissions merci beaucoup
monsieur savoir se savoir et
ex-directeur adjoint à la sûreté du
québec je vous rappelle que dans
quelques minutes il y aura le discours
du pape qui s'adresse donc aux gens qui
sont derrière nous sur les plaines
d'abraham parce que tout est diffusé en
direct sur les plaines et je me permets
alain rapidement puis l'on sort de votre
champ d'expertisé habituel mais envoyer
l'image de québec c'est splendide que
ces images là elles font le tour du
monde présentement c'est certain alors
imaginez vous maintenant que vous êtes
dans l'avion du pape une cinquantaine de
journalistes qui sont des journalistes
accrédités sur base permanente à la
salle de presse au vatican à ces gens le
suivent le peuvent sauter petit voyage
et il y en a tant que roussey ne sais
pas combien de voyages ce sont 37 5
voyages de france au tas
le fait est là il s'en vient au canada
ça va à l'ouest au bord d'un lac il ya
des images les qui sont saisissantes
mais je pense que tous ces journalistes
et là d'avoir un kodak tout neuf juste
pour ical ou et web llc agit en aval
ouais puis parce que c'est attendez je
veux un airbus 330 double u comme ça
atterrir à égalité avec à bord un chef
d'état mais aussi un être spirituel
comme le conclut m un leader spirituel
je pense que le voyage au canada vote
donnée à ces images des images c'est ça
québec on a nos images dans l'ouest on
ajuste russe a donné ses dix matière
c'est le lac je pense que il qu'à 8 ça
va faire du marché intérieur dans les
journaux de ses journalistes et on sera
là en direct oui vous y serez n'ont pas
souhaité leur usage kg on y sera c'est
dans notre couverture spéciale allait
bouchard et sociologue des religions
l'état la faculté théologie de sciences
religieuses de l'université laval /
chars bonjour bonjour d'abord je veux
vous entendre sur une observation
générale de ce que vous avez vu de ce
voyage du pape depuis son arrivée
dimanche
moi ce qui me frappe dans un premier
temps c'est commun
il y en a trop où il y en a pas mal
c'est cette frontière là elle bouge
beaucoup et ça ça me rappelle les
relations entre les autochtones et
l'église catholique dans ce qu'on
appelle l'inculturation bien la
dimension dans les émissions précédentes
où
est-ce qu'on intègre des éléments de
de rituels tient dans la mer et vice
versa et ça ça fait partie de l'histoire
et ce qu'on regarde c'est que tout d'un
coup
bas il se pose la question est ce qu'il
ya une tentative de récupération ou une
tentative de contamination dépendant du
côté où on est on peut avoir les deux
observations et 102 analyse exactement
et c'est ça qui s'est produit en contre
pour la messe à edmonton quand on s'est
posé la question mais où sont les
éléments là
exactement d'ailleurs il ya quand même
une marque avec vous en vendeur de noir
entre les deux il y avait un moyen de de
trouver de l'aide mais là moi la
question je veux poser mais c'est mais
pourquoi pourquoi parce que ce que
j'avais sous les yeux c'était un bape
françois qui avec le comité qui
organisait la célébration ont décidé
qu'ils auraient peu de choses donc on
avait françois qui était dans ses
pantoufles
donc vaticane sont vus ou tout au moins
catholique romaine mais qui étaient
ouverts et les sons le vus dans son
homélie et ce pour moi c'est ça la
rencontre entre les cultures c'est de ne
pas se dégénérer pour plaire à l'autre
mais d'être authentique imeda est ouvert
à l'autre et ça je pense qu'on le voit
dans nos têtes et inclusive quand même
attelé de l'homme aurait pu montrer
qu'on aurait pu faire preuve dès 1000
voyage le voyage pour terminer peut-être
conseil dessus c'est ce qu'annonce aux
jeunes musulmans sont derrière peut-être
que demain la belle s'est découvert des
choses mais a pour moi ça ça pose pas
problème c'est c'est vraiment une
question parce que tout au long de
l'histoire du canada s'est posé cette
question là lorsqu'il n'ya par exemple
des prêtres ont décidé de mettre coiffe
d'un chef sur le tabernacle pour cergy
est un grand chef il ya des américains
ont dit non non non non on se croisera
et on a eu la même chose avec la coiffe
sur la tête du pape et jean yanne
je veux amener le sociologue en vous
parce que là c'est l'analyse des
sociétés me des mouvements de société
regardons derrière en vous et moi là on
s'attendait à des milliers de personnes
voire dizaines de milliers de personnes
mais avec quelques centaines
moi je crois surprise puisque l'église
catholique au québec et même on peut
parler au canada traverse une grave
crise
ça commençait après la deuxième guerre
mondiale mais ça s'est accéléré depuis
les années 2000 depuis les années 2000
la demande de au sacrement donc baptêmes
mariages et funérailles chute de façon
dramatique a maté mini ottawa et les
documents sont actuellement
après ça les croyants souci chute
même chose qui était stable depuis fort
longtemps l'identification religieuse
85% de la population du canada ou du
québec s'identifier à une institution
religieuse c'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
on vend les chiffres au mois d'octobre
statistique canada a tous les 10 ans fin
recensement en 2001 11 et 24 % des
canadiens qui s'identifier comme étant
sans religion à ciani bien d'avoir des
chasseurs en australie vient de sortir
les chiffres on est passée de 29% à 39 %
il faut s'attendre à une augmentation
d'à peu près 10% ce qui veut dire qu'il
ya grosso modo le tiers de la population
du canada ne s'identifie plus anodin à
une religieuse et ça me semble question
d entre eux que le fait qu'ils aient peu
de gens ici parce que la commission
vérité réconciliation
lorsqu'on arrive dans la section
réconciliation tous les temps dit il
faut que tous les canadiens soient
impliqués dans cette démarche là et là
mais je m'aperçois que on a là une
occasion où l'on doit prendre conscience
de ce qui s'est passé mais de ce qui se
passe encore parce que là on pointe du
doigt les pensionnats faut pas oublier
qu'en 1939 on a retourné un bateau ou
des juifs allemands a essayé de se
réfugier sur canada pour les jeux
retourner en allemagne ai je besoin
d'ajouter joyce et jake one
puis même - bref lorsque j'étais aux
primaires le vendredi après midi on
achetait des petits chinois 25
donc épique on le veut car ensemble
attentes à la mosquée quelques semaines
plus tard un champ d'achat la perception
des québécois de la communauté musulmane
n'avait pas changé alors sonné tout un
travail à faire sur choix et c'est là où
ça me questionne c'est à dire que face
au désintérêt de cet événement là
actuellement à même si on a une bonne
couverture médiatique mais si on regarde
la le déplacement des foules et moi je
me questionne sur l'impact de sa re
souris foule il faudra voir pour la
suite donc j'espère qu'on va être
capable de comme le veut la maxima de
cette rencontre le marcheur
ya un mot qu'on n'a pas entendu beaucoup
qu'on utilise un mot souvent en
politique la fiabilité dans la demande
de pardon du pape exigeons les chrétiens
nous
implique tous les chrétiens dans la
demande de pardon mais pas
nécessairement psion le tellement répété
pas nécessairement les instructions
l'église est ce que le principe
d'imputabilité dont on parle souvent
politique ça plaît dans les grandes
religions
il faut que ça va dépendre d'une
religion à l'autre là c'est sûr qu'on
est face à l'institution où il ya une
organisation décentralisée
on a sont représentés
rapidement cédé la avec les cartes vidéo
tour qui sont désertés au ministre donc
dans cette perspective le oui mais
d'autres noms et et mais là aussi il
faut voir en terme de simplement de
régulation al interne il faut voir que
la personne qui prend une décision dans
un espace géographique si les vikes à
ses
responsables donc on s'imagine
ou dans la mesure où si ça s'était
produit sur quelques années on pourrait
toujours dit ça m'a échappé mais le pape
est capable on peut regarder benoît
sineau fait à coup de centaines de fois
d'expulser des prêtres de l'église est
capable de faire ça on est capable
d'être une communauté religieuse on ne
veut pas ceux ci sinon on fait cela on a
mis sous tutelle une organisation de
femmes qui s'intéressent au féminisme
dans l'église catholique on est capable
d'aller loin et quand même comme
institution jeune ado rome et dans ce
cas-ci pendant toutes ces décennies là
on ne sut de toute évidence j'avais
d'éviter cette limite d'âge on savait
tout ça et on n'a rien dit alors que le
pape pourrait peser à l'époque il y en a
eu quelques-uns il y en a 1 quelques
banques avaient dû dire une bonne idée
on arrête est ce que ça peut être sympa
plus appliquée plus il ya plus le
système du passionnant et plus lors la
question que je me pose c'est est ce que
quelque chose de semblable peut se
reproduire comme société est ce qu'on
est à même de créer des choses
semblables je regarde au sud de la
frontière il ya des moments où je me dis
bon on dirait que oui diop les trois
dieppois juste des réjouissances dans la
fin des pensionnats il ya aussi on
devrait conserver une certaine méfiance
à la gare à notre propre regard vrai
qu'un plus mal et je suis d'accord avec
avec toi quand tu parles de des
structures du vatican c'est épaules mais
je me dis un exemple je parle avec des
religieuses qui ont participé
directement par les communautés à s'est
passé dans l'oise un des pensionnaires
mais nous on savait pas nous on voulait
vraiment denis de l'éducation
la faire et fait de bonnes intentions et
pavie bon état
effectivement et il faut voir que rien
n'unit commission d'enquêté sur les
pensionnaires même à la fin du 19e
siècle qui en avait pour dénoncer
l'insalubrité ont dénoncé le fait que
les revenus en fonction du nombre
d'enfants qui étaient accueillis donc
surpopulation problème de tuberculose et
s'était retirée et jamais une
institution que ce soit l'église que ce
soit les gouvernements les mêmes la
population générale en réagissant à cet
événement alors que nous vivons tous
ensemble cette salade ça pourrait faire
partie de cet éveil collectif alem chars
oui c'est ça qu'on souhaitait
c'est ce qu est ce que c'est ce qui se
produit à dit il ya des gens là par
exemple à l'atelier des gens qui sont la
pire plusieurs personnes qui me l'ont
dit personnellement j rep or il faut
trop chaud il retrouve en héros sécurité
on va le regarder à la télé alors c'est
peut-être ce bien que c'est pour ça
qu'il faut le dire il faut se le répéter
c'est
jamais plus il faut plus jamais cru ça
laisse penser la même chose actuellement
pour nous messieurs
même genre merci beaucoup de votre
participation jeudi messieurs parce que
on va aller on voit l'organisation qui
ici aussi que ça c'est fait ce temps
record normalement on a peut-être deux
ans pour organiser ça là ça s'est fait
en quelques semaines seulement un peu
plus tôt cette semaine j'ai discuté avec
jasmin lemieux lefebvre qui est fait
partie de ce comité organisateur qui
nous parlait de la logistique et du défi
on va écouter ajas mais est tout de
suite par la suite en principe on
devrait avoir tout de suite dans la
suite ça fait des choix de cinq ans la
décision d'attendre le discours du pape
les promesses une coupure
jasmin ses immenses organisera une
visite papale normalement on y passe
unanimité deux ans sap combien tu as
pour québec environ huit semaines huit
semaines ça défile logistique qui est
relevé maintenant parce que le il a eu
oui
je viens vous dire quelque chose quand
le pape est arrivé dimanche
il ya eu un premier contact avec le
secrétaire général l'archevêque de
moncton et puis il ya tenu à faire le
relais à toutes les équipes qui
travaillent sur le terrain en disant de
quelques années j'aurais pensé
impossible de pouvoir organiser des
visites comme ça le pape tu parles de
françois
quelques semaines qui il voulait
s'assurer que tout le monde déjà
edmonton nunavut à québec soit au
courant qu'il y apprécier tous les
efforts qui ont été
je sais qu'ils ont été en quelques
semaines lancée par pleinement des
bénévoles pour la plupart il reste que
vous devez marcher parce que je le pense
vous devez marcher sur un fil d'affaires
en ce sens que c'est un pèlerinage et le
dit lui même or c'est une visite papale
pénitentielle ça peut pas être ça peut
paraître comme les jmj ça peut pas être
comme 1984 donc il faut vous assurer
d'avoir une organisation qui répond à
ceux à cette situation bien parti
en prison toujours l'expérience des
survivants et survivants des pensionnats
autochtones parce que à raison les
différents groupes d'autochtones nous
l'ont rappelé souvent je pense qu'ils
faisaient leur travail de nous dire
oublier paul la rencontre pourquoi
françois vient au canada c'est pour
aller à leur rencontre et leur exprimer
sur leur territoire une demande de
pardon c'est historique que cette
rencontre l'a 85 ans françois qui
choisit de laisser de côté pour des
raisons évidentes de santé des voyages
très important à malte en afrique et il
choisit d'être ici parce qu'il sait que
parmi les survivants survivants il ya
beaucoup de très âgés et que leur chaque
mois contre l'arrivée à l'aéroport et
son transport vers la citadelle quels
sont les défis alors bien sûr ça va être
très très courant ce qui suit va l'être
la télévision ces cinq à dix minutes les
signes on qu'on va pouvoir recevoir de
l' aéroport alors accueille
principalement par des dignitaires y ait
toujours des survivants à chaque endroit
est là donc on se dirige vers les
plaines et pendant ce temps leur chez à
le souligner parce que c'est vraiment
important il ya les marcheurs 1 qui ont
quitté macho iasi pointe-bleue le
dernier pensionnés autochtones au québec
qui a fermé en 91 s'était pas longtemps
alors eux ils vont était arrivé la
veille le 26 un bac es et partiront le
matin à 9 heures jusque sur les plaines
pour converger en attaque exactement et
là ils vont avoir 45 minutes à eux il
est très important que c'est pas ben là
vous devez nous donner savoir exactement
puis accompagner tout ça on a vraiment
tenu leur donner un espace après bien
sûr la rencontre à la citadelle il y
aura
rencontres protocolaires un discours
public et tout de suite après ça c'est
ce 17h30 attendu un toujours plus ou
moins il ya une flexibilité dans ses
voyages là où le pape voss se promener
sur les plaines québec c'est québec et
sainte anne de beaupré et je viens
sainte anne de beaupré c'est les deux
endroits où il ya les plus importants
bain de foule c'est clair ça ça doit
d'un défi logistique pour vous organiser
oui c'est un de vos prix le tout une
dynamique de billets et là on le
rappelle un les gens qui n'ont pas de
billet s'il vous plaît ne vous présentez
pas les routes sont fermées de toute
façon exactement il ya tout un service
de navettes et françois c'est toujours
dans ses voyages à pouvoir parler
j'irai l'église et aux gens qui par la
suite une fois que françois est parti
vont devoir poursuivre dans les paroles
et les gestes
l'ours est essentielle aussi d'avoir un
moment comme ça et le cadre de la
basilique-cathédrale
notre-dame-de-québec est parfait et tout
de suite après il y aura de façon privée
souple et avec les évêques et plein de
leader autochtone des gens qui veulent
poursuivre sur cette voie de
réconciliation
on sent que la venue de françois permet
dé débuter un nouveau chapitre dernier
point le vendredi 10 autres rencontres
avec les leaders autochtones avant de
partir pour lequel oui exactement alors
il rencontre aussi ses amis de sa
communauté
mais un moment aussi
avec
des survivants sur une vente des leaders
et l'asse pour l'est du canada il y aura
des représentants je reviens sur le
temps très restreint puis on va conclure
là dessus ça a été bon et défis
logistiques on vient bien de comprendre
vous êtes prêts sur une échelle de
pourcentage vous êtes prêt à quel
pourcentage
écoutez moi je pense qu'on essaie
sincèrement moi je pense qu'on est
vraiment prêt avec la marge de manoeuvre
bien sûr que des événements de cette
ampleur là on va devoir s'ajuster à la
dernière minute chaque jour on doit
ficelé des éléments mais avec l'équipe
qui est en place que j'ai à saluer on a
travaillé fort mais c'est avec le coeur
qui je vous dis avec les survivants
survivante première place parce que
c'est pour eux qu'on fait ce travail au
jasmin lemieux lefebvre merci merci à
vous
allez à l'image qu'on voit en permanence
c'est la porte
la résidence officielle de la
gouverneure générale du canada
présentement il ya une rencontre privée
avec le premier ministre justin trudeau
olivero tout à l'heure pour qu'on accole
un photographe d'une prise de photo
officielle et le discours officiel du
pape et de la gouverneur générale vont
venir dans une trentaine 2009 est ce que
c'est à ce moment ci que l'étape
diplomatique du voyage je pense parce
que leur c'est derrière des portes aux
touches je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ce
qui se passe en tout cas je sais que
parler mais là je sais que c'est un
moment diplomatie les portes sont
fermées que ce qu'ont aussi le pape veut
dire être idiot bombay a lieu je suis là
je sais pas ce qu'ils faisaient j'en ai
aucune idée mais le pape est un
diplomate important et ses relations
avec les chefs d'état sort on peut poli
on parle toujours du chef de l'église
catholique mais c'est un chef d'état qui
ont des relations diplomatiques tout le
monde sait que quand on parle de saint
siège et il est celui qui est sur le
saint siège et le successeur de qui de
saint pierre alors quand on parle du
saint-siège ont pas de la succession de
ce1 de saint pierre ça va loin la
diplomatie vaticane par exemple qu'ils
ont un statut d'observateur permanent il
n'a pas beaucoup à l'onu des comme ça et
ils ont un statut d' ça l'aurait été
accordée ya longtemps mais à quel titre
t pain de batiscan qui reconnut c'est
pas le pack comme chef d'étape c'est le
successeur de saint pierre qui est
reconnu alors on a là une autorité qu'il
n'est pas une autorité avec des
frontières c'est tout petit fils à jo
gains à l'instar des trois avocats c'est
pas ça qui compte c'est donc l'autorité
morale qu'on reconnaît dassa alors quand
l'événement le vatican joue souvent avec
les deux à dire le sapin le saint-siège
le vatican ça dépend des moments assez
commode des fois de parler du vatican
parce que son petit et a laissé ben
pratique de temps en temps dit le saint
père et le saint siège parce que ça fait
référence à un déploiement à l sagesse
aussi probablement oui je sais ce que
c'est ce qu'ils ont aujourd'hui droit et
se disaient les les référents morale la
première fois qu'un pape sy talent à
l'onu c'est par six et c'est un put ce
qu'il avait dit nous sommes ici comme la
conscience
le service de la conscience et c'est
simple aujourd'hui on n'a pas la même
idée à cause de tous les scandales qui
ont affligé l'église vrai pédophile à
l'échelle la fenêtre
on connaît nous au canada avec la
question des pensionnats on est capable
de mettre des bémols maintenant cette
conscience ou cette morale il n'empêche
que c'était la prétention de l'église
ils ont développé au fil des ans au fil
des décennies et des siècles un système
de diplomatie qui est illégal est
illégale et quoi ils ont je fasse oui de
terriblement efficace parce que partout
ailleurs des curés partout alors ils ont
un réseau d'information qui qui
remontent au vatican très facilement
nous on annonce mais il ya aussi un
ambassades et c'est vrai à peu prés d'un
pool nonce apostolique c'est lui qui est
un peu l'ambassadeur du vatican car
exactement avec le langage avec le
langage suspects du vatican il
entretient des relations avec je suis un
chiffre que je pensais 189 sais pas
pourquoi ça paraît dans ma tête mes
bâtons pas loin de 200 pays c'est plus
que le canada entretient avec les autres
pays et il ya la tarde pas mal de gens
qui se sont installés qui ont maintenant
un l'ambassade près le saint-siège comme
ça qu'il faut le dire il ya des
représentations là qui rencontre le
saint père quand le saint père une fois
par annie rend compte les médias
internationaux sont nombreux quand il
raconte aussi les jeunes la diplomatie
ils sont nombreux c'est un service de la
diplomatie qui qu'on ne peut pas
négliger et que certains détestent on a
surgi ni vous allez trouver des gens qui
vont opposer ces gens là travaillent
dans les coulisses comme un service
pratique travaillent dans les coulisses
pour faire avorter tout ce qui pourrait
toucher l'avancement de la cause des
femmes tout ce qui concerne par exemple
la contraception ou précisé mme à
l'avortement et il ya déjà des gens
racontent on m'a déjà new york qui
déteste le saint-siège parce que ils
sont plus puissants qu on l imagine
n'ont peut-être pas de gants d'argent
axa maison un réseau ils ont résulté et
ils se parlent ils sont capables
d'actions jogging ils ont pris un par là
depuis des centaines d'années ce qui
fait genre de rôle à ce qui fait en
sorte que ça on se questionne sur ce qui
se dit derrière ces portes championnat
c'est un morceau de sa la crise y est
vous l'avez aperçu brièvement on est
très heureux de l'avoir avec nous chez
lauda il adressa des parades à
celle aux dates sénatrice coup et oui
vous étiez hamas quoi 6 au moment où il
ya eu les excuses la demande de pardon
j'ai entendu plein de réactions j'ai
entendu des gens qui disaient bondi à ne
pas assez fait doute qu'il soit fait du
bien puis on dit toujours que c'est
personnel j'ai posé la même question
tantôt à konrad sioui vous connaissez
bien qu'est ce que vous savez faire je
suis absente j'ai senti
la colère j'ai senti que la douceur j'ai
senti
ces bosses qui dit peut rager sentiers
c'est tout ce qui s'y passe on parle pas
de chose qui sont encore trop présente
le g comme rebaisser les épaules et
c'est là où je me suis rappelé à temps
il ya du monde à côté de moi que c'est
encore plus fort parce qu'ils étaient
des ex pensionnaires le coupe à côté de
moi en avant en arrière et dans la foule
alors je me suis calmé en me disant ok
je marchais à côté d'eux à la vitesse
qu'ils ont envie qu'on marche
on en a beaucoup parlé de votre mère
elle était invitée justement et c'est à
la dig ans c'est vous qui êtes allé
mais je suis allé dans le code
il faut en finir avec le système des
passionnés souvent parlé il ya quelques
jours vous marrer comme l avait réagi le
temps a fait son oeuvre un peu saoul ou
jo oui mais je lèverai réflexion la
radio tués par les puits et il était en
colère elle voulait pape après sa suite
après les excuses de saint marcel la
haye les avait écoutés puis elle avait
beaucoup de peine et le lendemain sur
plus tout à l'heure il ya quelques
heures de sa c'est elle qui s'inquiètent
pour moi maintenant avec ce que je vais
bien alors j'ai du bon du jeu voilà que
se met en colère de côté tu acceptes pas
des excuses c'est ton droit maman mais
la beauté là dedans c'est que elle
respecte ceux et celles qui ont envie
d'absorber les excuses elle dans sa tête
et il faut plus que des excuses
tellement que sa fille son fils par
pauline ou pour m 1
il plein d'autres réalités mais quel
courage cette femme
tu parlais de l'histoire de l'église al
qadr parce que quand j'aperçois j'étais
au sommet qui parle de l'église handicap
je parlais a pas de liste un coeur des
mois l'église unie l'église unie couette
sait le faire gaubert qui me racontait
sa vie il ya des raisons été parmi les
premiers à s'excuser au premier peuple
pour les pensionnaires et il me dit un
moment donné on a foutu dehors notre
service juridique parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte qu'on a vu c'est là des
sommes qui étaient inutiles puis ils se
sont fait d'ailleurs pas ça fait pas ça
vous allait détruire votre église ils
vont vous poursuit il on fasse appareil
qui se sont excusés les chefs sont
sortis de leurs six pilotes audi on
reconnaît et j'ai trouvé ça formidable
ils ont dit on reconnaît vos excuses
elles sont sincères
mais on ne les accepte pas comme pour le
pam a pas pour le moment j'ai demandé à
gold a gelé rappelait il ya quelques
jours je me dis mais alors ça fait déjà
30 ans leur fille ils n'ont toujours pas
accepté et en ce moment ça alors entre
le moment là bas sont visibles
nécessairement accepté les excuses de
quelqu'un parce que s'excuse ou est-ce
qui a pas entre le moment d'accepter et
autres chocs ya un chemin à parcourir le
pardon est pas l'homme de mule way pour
ma part les excuses je les ai je trouve
qu'un aspect qui a été sincère mais ce
qui manque le sait la violence
on n'a pas eu de violence physique mais
spirituelle et mentale pas sexuel et
juste pour vous dire qu on pas beaucoup
d écoles résidentielles mais il ya les
écoles de jour c'est les mêmes qu il est
même prêt qu'ils ont enseigné moi dans
ma petite école à malioténam après ça on
parle de la deuxième et troisième
générations on a été agressé par des
personnes qui ont été dans les
pensionnats ce supplément dans la
préparation de ses émissions là j'ai
regardé beaucoup de reportages dont
certains plusieurs de vous avec qu'il ya
des gens qui racontait gpo je suis pas
allé dans un pensionnat mon père n'y est
pas allé mais un gode monde de mon coin
y est à l'ipcc intervenu tout ce qu'ils
connaissaient juste l avis allant
d'agressions sexuelles et comme femme
gtx les dommages collatéraux qui émane
de la même racine ça fait mal quand nous
avons entendu dizaines des centaines de
témoignages de femmes disparues et
assassinées
quelle est la partie juste portion peu
le camp ce film et quelle est la part de
l'héritage des pensionnats autochtones
qui avait dans ces drames le contenu que
vous racontez votre question est
précieuse parce que j'avais un besoin
ok bon bain peut-être pas tant que ça
après avoir traversé tous les
territoires j'étais malheureusement
ébranlé où chaque kit savoir qu'une des
racines
d'écosystèmes excepté ces politiques
coloniales cesser les pensionnaires et
la colonisation donc violence coloniale
qu'elle a été partout ensuite on va voir
quand on parle de violences et sévices
et on va à l'agression sexuelle se sont
tous et toutes des personnes qui ont été
dans les pensionnats jusqu'à moi même je
peut plus prétendre que c'était pottoks
mais ça fait beaucoup penser petit quand
on dit je dois souvent cet exemple je
trouve probant saganash c'est un corps
est en plein sur la place publique au
tir à consulter avant son frère à sa
famille à lui j'ai parlé à sa fille qui
n'a jamais mis les pieds dans un
pensionnat et pourtant dû pendant une
demi heure une demi heure une heure et
vous allez constater que même s'il a
jamais mis les pieds dans un pensionnat
à l'ailé risser de tout ce que son père
a vécu et on allait sa femme des hells
aucun doute alors tu quand on sait
multigénérationnel savait pas dire que
il ya plusieurs générations qui ont
habité les passes et un responsable
c'est que les conséquences parlé de
dommages collatéraux les dommages
transcende les générations et même si on
est un parfait innocent j'aimais me
lisent jamais lu à propos des passionnés
on risque d'être le porteur de cet
héritage ça démontre à quel point le
chemin est long avant d'aboutir à
peut-être est-ce qu'on essaye de vie lol
je sais pas sur les parviendra mais il
ya quelque chose de si discrète il ya
les mots sont importants une question
que j'ai posée à konrad sioui tout à
l'appui je pense que je veux l'imposer à
tous les inscrits représentants des
premières nations qui viendront à cette
faune est ce que dans la tristesse et
l'atrocité de tout ce qui était vécue
depuis les derniers mois en particulier
depuis la découverte existantes est ce
qu'au moins dans sa phase où on se parle
que je connais cette réalité loft les
gens qui nous regardent ce soit
connaissent maintenant cette réalité
d'eau qui compterait mieux une certaine
douleur je suis de l'école moi je pense
ou du portage quand on dit ont vu une
enquête ou une commission un autre
commission open autre apport ça permet
de faire cette éducation populaire où
cette pédagogie dans un format légal
l'historique une chute après c'est ce
qui est important c'est que
rappelons-nous la commission vérité la
mfa d'heure pour les femmes je laissais
chaque mois notre soeur qui me guide
dans des circonstances atroces on est
tous et tout ébranlées elop les
résultats que l'on fait le tour de la
planète encore une fois puis on va
démontrer au tour de la planète à
travers mon souffrance on sait debout
encore qu'on a envie dès que doublé on
va guérir ou on est en train on l'est
déjà guérie en version libre poussé où
on va embrasser mais aussi beaucoup je
veux aller voir pourquoi qu'on se tient
debout et pourquoi les gens choisi de se
déplacer ici ma collègue camille
carpentier
je vous le rappelle est sur les plaines
d'abraham elle est avec nous pour rendre
compte de ce qui se vit pendant que nous
on est sur cette tribune là il ya des
gens qui vivent probablement un moment
important camille j'attends donc
effectivement il ya moins de monde que
ce qu'on pensait mais ceux qui sont là
il tenait mordicus voulait vais sûrement
mal
[Musique]
retard et bruno parce qu'en plus des
survivants des des membres de familles
des survivants qui sont vraiment là pour
entendre les excuses - mais pas les
excuses du pack les plusieurs chrétiens
au sud se sont déplacés j'ai vu les
c'est de montrer l'oeuvre ou est-ce
qu'on en est le dans le nombre de
personnes qui sont sur les plaines en ce
moment d'autres on peut facilement
estimé à peut-être quelques milliers de
personnes et vous croyez c'est loin
d'être pleins et là on est loin du sang
les quelques personnes apprend on
estimait qu'on anticipait dans les
dernières semaines et parmi la foule des
gens qui sont là depuis effectivement
plusieurs heures ce après sont arrivés
avant midi très tôt ce matin là pour
voir le parc françois pour assister à
cette journée historique
quand même et nous un truc con de parler
à certains chrétiens qui sont là depuis
cet après midi bruxelles est important
pour eux d'être là et d'assister à ses
excuses on va essayer quelques personnes
qui ont envie
[Musique]
on vient le soutenir pour la démarche de
réconciliation
puis bien demander pardon rouzet dit m
moi je bois pis idée assez de re se
réconcilier avec les indiens l'os et des
blessures intérieures donc si ça peut
les aider tant mieux mais faut vivre le
temps présent puis regarder vers
l'avenir
et cet homme que vous venez d'entendre
j'ai d'ailleurs demandé bruno est ce que
vous vous attendiez à voir plus de monde
aujourd'hui son plein il m'a dit qu'il
n'est pas vraiment surpris de voir le
nombre de personnes il dit c'est pas
surprenant quand on regarde les églises
se vident c'est pas surprenant de voir
que les plaies ne sont pas remplies on
n'est pas en 1984 lors de la visite du
pape jean paul ii et donc il ya
plusieurs personnes par contre qu'ils
vont écouter avec attention le discours
du pape qui doit être diffusée sur les
plaines dans quelques minutes
merci calais chez nos têtes les gens qui
sont ici sont des suppôts nécessairement
les représentants des premières nations
sinon bing et comme on fera une
démonstration culturel points des
premières nations mais des gens qui sont
ici c'est des gens qui veulent voir le
pack wii et j'étais surprise pourquoi il
parle de moi et
moi je fume pas entendu on parle de vous
lasser car dezir pendant votre domicile
pour vous dire un marchand tout à
l'heure sur la rue grande allée
je voulais pas être ce temps je vais pas
vous manquer j'étais un petit peu
délinquance j'ai traversé j'avais pas le
droit et il ya une femme qui m'a arrêté
le g10 aiea va me faire comprendre que
j'ai et l'été dans l'émotion a dit je
suis venu pour vous pour les premiers
peuples j'ai vu monsieur voilà j'ai vu
le papillon je vous vois pas là les
larmes à m'a fait pleurer pas 10 je veux
faire partie du changement
mettez-vous cela on a on ne touche le
coeur des gens avec les sépultures des
enfants il ya personne qui restent
indifférents
première des choses il ya pour plusieurs
ça a été ben voyons dans mon pays ait
fait ça voyons donc mes ancêtres ont
fait ça passe a été commandé un
cautionnement écran plat de ce premier
indice mcdonough c'est un gouvernement
du canada qui l'avait commandé et ça
fait en sorte que ce la découverte de
ces sépultures probablement est venu
toucher plus temps vous disiez tantôt on
va répéter encore pu monter rond mais on
dirait que cette fois là parce que
c'était des enfants ce n'est pourtant
rien on l'a dit on le répète
je sais ce que je dois déjà là dessus ah
ouais je pense à
mary wilson qui est dit combien de
combien ou encore les taux de sel ou
encore cinq là qu'on vieillit on a
entendu chacun de témoignages déjà en
avant 2-1 contre les
hells au delà et elle raconte sur monde
on fait des reportages ont écrit ces
histoires là la commission publie un
rapport avec une foule de 2014 à 14 ans
tous et ce qu'on retient c'est la 58 où
on demande au peuple de savoir si mais
on savait donc tout ça il a appris
ça au printemps de relie pau que 12 mai
à saint louis mais c'est déjà ça oui oui
pour ma part c'est comme quand je vous
dis c'est important de faire des
commissions d'enquêté si on n'avait pas
eu ces commissions la banque peut-être
qu'on n'aurait pas parlé de ça puisque
des rumeurs ouais alors que là nos
paroles sont devenus des vérités au
coeur des gens dans le cas des gens
sévérité là sont des faits qui fait qu'
ils vont pouvoir se coller à la science
aux faits scientifiques et aux preuves
qu'on est habitués qu'on exige alors
quand on va dire la prochaine fois je
pense que ma famille sont enterrés là
bord ben on va pouvoir vite avoir une
technologie mais on ceux ci n'auront
peut-être moins et c'est la réponse sera
peut-être dans les fameuses archives un
sol qu'est ce qu'on en sait de ses
archives qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que je
comprends que la demande et à qui on
espère toujours que le pape dise il a
fait de son pèlerinage pénitentielle
ouvre l'accès à ces fameuses archives
qu'est ce qu'on en sait elles sont
précieuses les archives vont permettre
de mettre la preuve scientifique à la
parole ou aux récits des gens lorsqu'on
voit le chercheur qui revenu de rome en
disant bon j'ai pas eu pourtant mais
j'étais en mesure de voir qu'on savait
qu'il y avait des prêtres et puis curé
qui avaient des attirances ou vers les
jeunes fantone fallait les déplacés les
envies les mettre ailleurs on n'a pas
fait de procès puis on n'a pas fait de
réparation pour les victimes on a juste
ton cinéma lier que continuer ailleurs
alors les preuves sont là on pourrait
trouver par exemple l'identité des
enfants on pourrait trouver la raison de
leurs déchets moi je sais comme ancien
commissaire dans certaines fosses
communes au québec où sont certains
bébés enterrer
les jets on connaît maintenant le vue
celui qui portait la coiffe
sur la tête du pape lancé comme ça on
disait oui on sait comme ça et tu disais
qu'il ya participé aux opérations radar
pour essayer de trouver voir qu'est ce
qu'ils avaient sous le sol le chiffre
que j'ai retenu 7 7 ils ont creusé déjà
soient les décisions font preuve il dit
qu'il a trouvé un cercueil sur lequel il
y avait comme simple indication
d'identification d'un garçon et la
justice et c'est l'âge avec elle lui est
entré au pensionnat l'identifier
à partir du moment où on sait que on
sera peut-être pas grand-chose donc
commentait ce qu'on gère avec ça c'est
comme un deuil autour ne reconnaît que
l'idée de décider afin disparaissent la
chose la plus importante le moment donné
au cours de tennis ça va être de savoir
où sont ils
pour que je puisse terminer temps des
belles au moins peut-être que si c'est
ton blacks sont restreintes annan et
peut-être qu'elles le resteront toujours
les qu'on soit capable quelque part
entamé un deuil puis c'est possible nous
concerne et là aussi
on a dit que dans ces archives l'on
regarde l information
des étapes religieuse des petits
pensionnaires saisir il a eu sa première
communion
détaillé way est ce que est ce que vous
pensez que le détail de il a été malade
ils ont été peut-être agressé par un tel
est ce qu'on va aller jusque là dans les
archives je peine à croire qu'on l'ait
détail certaines archives qui ont été
disponibles après des débats devant les
tribunaux lors de la commission de
vérité et réconciliation ont permis de
démontrer et cette équipe dans le
rapport que des enfants ont été utilisés
pour des essais de vitamines de
médicaments alors c'est parce que
c'était écrit noir sur blanc moi j'ai eu
accès des archives au québec pour
comprendre sont morts de quoi les
enfants qui sont jamais revenus ici au
québec un des hôpitaux basse à travers
le québec et c'était les communautés
religieuses et ensuite les toc qui a
fait les mêmes actions les détails
étaient moins clair que la communauté
religieuse
je me suis fait la réflexion puis en
regardant de certains reportages on
expliqué qu' à la fin de l'été des
autobus qui a vu là on allait chercher
pilotes des avions je me suis imaginé le
quartier où mes enfants ont grandi il y
avait plein d'enfants dans ce quartier
résidentiel hop je me suis on essaie d
fois pour comprendre de se l'approprier
à soi même puis je m'imaginais je puisse
imaginer sushi voulait des autobus qui
passe dans votre quartier on relance les
enfants à partir de 5 6 ans
probablement contre le gré du ballon
quand même arriver vous voulez envoyer
un enfant puis dans certains cas les
enfants avait tellement été
endoctrinés qui dix ans plus tard où 10
ans plus tard qu'ils revenaient
connaissait plus lent puis reconnaissait
plus la tradition que leur valeur par
valeur leur inculquer quand on se le
place comme ça si tu h contes
contemporains imaginez ça dans mon
quartier plus plus de son enfant c'est
ce que j'ai entendu mon d'aider les
enfants dorment dans les rues chine chez
nous qui jouait il ya des communes et
communautés en entier qui était comme ça
qui fait comparaison elle et elle est
importante c'est inimaginable ça c'est
pas ce chiffre et c'est pour ça que le
pape vient s'excuser
qu'est-ce que vous est ce que vous
attendez qu'il aille un peu plus loin
dommage que je serai à sainte anne de
beaupré demain ouais est ce que parce
que on est vu dans l'ouest il a demandé
pardon on entend juste ce qu'il a dit et
son homélie suivant il était dans la
réconciliation par la suite il ya eu les
moyens nommé dit sur l'évangélisation et
il est revenu un peu sur l'importance
des grands moments des grands-mamans
domaine vous attendent à coup et je
m'attend je nous souhaite je me souhaite
que les vrais mots vont aussi faire
partie que c'est l'église non des
individus qui ont commis des gestes cet
important est qu on énumère toutes les
formes de violence faites en europe fo
qui osent nous souhaite puis je me
souhaite aussi que dans cette
réconciliation dans cet exercice et
c'est pas juste une ou des clips et
d'accueil le de s'attendre à ce que la
communauté religieuse la société en
général se sentent responsables ici dire
finalement en tout 35 labège le fasse
c'est pas juste aux autochtones désir
cra continue
on était intelligent c'est la
responsabilité générale compte mais
c'est extrêmement difficile sur le plan
des structures de se reconnaître l'ata
et on ne sait toujours pas mambo impose
que le lien 18,6 la réalité de ce que
ces
paysages n'y a pas de non j'ai pas une
wii alors tu te pousse cette chose
conceptuel que fait beaucoup de tort
apparemment un peu comme quand on disait
c'est l'art autochtone qui dit donc par
mois ce français à ma porte je suis ses
toiles saly saly consomment peu ou pas
qu'est ce qui concerne le pape parce que
ça leur fait envie mais ces expressions
là je trouve elles ont leur place dans
un parti sco qui est intelligent
raisonnable et c'est ce soir c'était un
petit coq afin qu'il dérange un peu et
je dirais la même chose avec le pape
quand ils utilisent de certains
expression pour décrire ce qui s'est
passé c'est comme si la bataille des
idées plus quelques pans tour easy
beaucoup pour moi et beaucoup de gens
hésitent même des communautés
religieuses a alors une petite création
lors de commencer à comprendre qu'ils
avaient des organismes dont organismes
système dans le ciel quelques papic donc
lui était au courant peut-être pas
personnellement mais que l'église est au
courant que c'est quelque part inscrit
dans les gènes maintenant de cette
entreprise
gère plus de blizzard et comprendre
pourquoi c'est si difficile de faire ce
polar qui est attendu par le marché est
ce que ça changera quelque chose d'un
point de vue légal parce que des
poursuites et des encours des recours
collectifs si le pape venait à dire ce
que bien des gens voudraient qu'ils
aient c'est à dire nous comme
institution l'église avec le grand a
nous avons cautionner ça nous en sommes
désolés nos cjp chercher je veux qu'il
met ce parce que c'est ce que les gens
voudraient qu'ils disent ce qu'ils
disent qu'il va pas assez loin s'il fait
ça est ce qu'ils se placent dans une
position légale où il deviendrait ce
qu'on est tenté de marchander ou jeanne
mance et
c'était excellent question à ce qu'on
est en train de marchander la morale la
référence mourad l'autorité morale de
cette institution que 2000 entend
creuser web ainsi on c'était la fête
elle calcule va peut-être arriver tal
afar va perdre de l'argent et risque
c'est ça est-ce que c'est tout c'est la
bonne question qu'il faut poser je pense
est ce qu'on est en train de marchander
l'autorité morale de cette institution
là et si on joue autrement comme
l'église unie le faire vous me direz
quel web et les légendes et les dix en
tout cas c'est pas aussi massifs c'est
ce qu'ont fait un premier témoin
important dans
peut-être peut-être mais n'empêche que
tu l'achètes de l'elysée le caddie la
reine d'angleterre je sais pas s'ils
avaient voulu si on avait voulu vider
les coffres je pense qu'on a la plus
faible mais alors mais ici on allait au
travail en des épi si c'était avant de
laon 10 voire 10,6 de costa do in
business et ça que ça coûte pour
internet c'est ça c'est ça le prix de
l'honnêteté c'est ça le prix de
l'intégrité et si on disait juste ça
parce que ça nous ça nous faciliterait
la tâche de dire que peut-être qu'on va
perdre quelques oeuvres d'art au vatican
que son mec vie qu est-ce qu ici on perd
dès qu'elle est ce qu est ce que ce
serait plus raisonnable parce que bon
nombre de gens à dormir et budget mais
je trouve que
je veux pas que ça paraisse déplacer
mais des fois on seulement est ce que
c'est une stratégie de genre c'est
n'étant pas du tout expertes et je ne
suis pas juriste mais mon mouvement
petit coeur me dit que le fait que des
enjeux à travers la planète s'est pas
seulement auprès des peuples autochtones
qui a eu des agressions sexuelles ou
d'autres formes de sévices et de
violences
je pense qu'on sait le la jurisprudence
amène aussi à des compensations de
l'argent les programmes des changements
est donc c'est peut-être une porte qui
n'osent pas ou ne veulent pas ouvrir
mais c'est un feeling c'est sale ça
alors on dira que c'était ça le prix
pour avoir cette autorité morale qui est
par ailleurs je me dis si on regarde le
cas du québec l'on peut regarder
ailleurs d'amendé mais ma part c'est en
italie la chute de la prise est allé
calmement l'attentât s'est produit de
toute façon alors ici et si ça au
contraire ça venait donner à
nouvel engouement un nouveau respect
pour l'institution catholique que d'été
voilà voici la vérité je sais pas est ce
que de toute façon les de l'egypte va
disparaître mais on voit bien qu'ils ont
apprises de temps en temps ils sont dans
le rouge mais
c'est drôle ça va même à une réflexion
que j'ai peur de vous entendre là dessus
au moment des excuses pendant les
célébrations conte de vue hier au lac
saint jean notamment je vois des
dizaines voire des centaines de
représentants des premières nations qui
sont là et qui sont de fervents croyable
puis vous en avez vu à côté est ce que
ça vous
étonne puis maintenant j'ai grandi avec
mano con la petite marie qui était connu
par la communauté religieuse et le
traduit le missel en langue union avec
d'autres femmes dont elle était très
proche donc moi j'ai jamais été touchés
ou violentés par un prêt tout incurie
mano comme était là
alors je pense longtemps jeu des
franchissements contre tiko raisons qui
t'ont enlever ton nom moi ma langue les
passionnel j'ai 17 ans je suis révolté
puis toujours douce a dit moi ça me fait
une douceur
les dernières paroles avant son décès
j'espère que tu vois quoi au petit jésus
tu étais pas capable de me juger alors
j'ai baptisé mais tu mets sous mes cinq
enfants
par respect mais après cela j'ai lâché
prise que je me suis dit les gens sont
bien atteints sont bien dans le chemin
rouge sont bien en telle religion
dentelle spiritualité j'ai des membres
de ma famille qui se sont complètement
je pensais que le terme apostasier alors
ce pour moi je le reste toujours avec
respect maintenant j'ai lanchais prix du
collège yat-il lada puis on a souvent
entendu des gens qui vont d'autres
victimes dans d'autres sphères de
prêtres pédophiles
continue de croire et moi quelqu'un qui
m'a déjà raconté un jour je crois plus à
l'église mais je crois que c'est ce
qu'il ya de soin de dire oui je gens
embarquent port dans l'église dans tout
protocolaire piste à certains égards ce
qu'on vit ici aujourd'hui mais je sens
que j'ai un contact spirituelle avec un
dieu est ce que c'est bien sur ce je le
vois je l'entends j'ai des amis lorsque
nous étions plus jeunes elles aussi
n'allait pas à l'église est pas sauf si
aujourd'hui je les vois c'est le pij
pourrait ça leur fait du bien ces
personnes là et pour danser il est
partout dieu où je peux le micom je veux
c'est comme ça je le reçois c'est comme
ça je pleurais ça alors je me dis bon
bain en autant qu'on nous impose pas si
on m'impose le jeu devient un petit peu
pour l'ancien délinquant tu mets un peu
plus la femme qui non non
ça c'est à toi soasta mois puis on peut
faire de belles choses ensemble c'était
comme une carpe à ce que tente ou avec
un mouchoir on disait on atteint des
sondages le qui sont assez marquant et
on verra probablement à nouveau
la chute dont les parts de marchés de
l'église catholique si je peux parler
comme ça hop la leur dans le marché de
la foi ou québec quand on veut le voir
dans canada aussi puisqu'on voit monter
systématiquement ce sont les gens qui se
disent sans religion ryan de religion
oui alors c'est pour eux
ça veut pas dire que on est un croyant
ou mécréants pour les uns ou pour les
autres ça veut dire que on ne s'aide
ceci plus à l'institution religieuse
qu'elle soit musulmane qu'ils soient
catholiques ou qu'elle se ferait si on
veut pas s'associer à une institution et
quand on gratte un peu on se raconte que
là bas il n'y a pas des gens qui se
disent chrétiens mais il s'associe pas
aux institutions et je ne peux très bien
comprendre pourquoi parce que vous
regardez les pages difficiles de cet
épisode mais pas juste le président est
aussi je peux très bien quoi et on
arrive aux visiteurs le pen le mystère
autochtone la 9ème ses plaies à chaque
année des portants avec tout le temps
qu'on a causé c'est pourquoi c'est
peut-être là la réponse peut-être que ça
ceci moins formellement à l'institution
mais il restait quelque chose de
fondamentalement bon pour eux mais
pourquoi juste pour les premières du
premier pas pour beaucoup de gens et je
me dis qu'il ya quelque chose qui t'a
fait se passer on n'a pas beaucoup et ce
petit quelque chose qui est en train de
se passer de l'ordre la spiritualité et
c'est moins religieux que spirituelle
dans la fausse nouvelle et les peuples
des premières nations ont une
spiritualité profonde oui simple
profonde et elle va être différente d'un
territoire ou d'un espace à l'autre mais
il ya des choses que pas mal enquête
tellement une belle expérience à travers
la difficulté de se propres mandats
c'est qu'on voit dans les protocoles qui
reste quand même des choses qui sont
partout les people qui nous relient d'un
peuple à l'autre le respect la
réciprocité l'interdépendance télé ben
voyons pic commun nous réussit de la
création se rassembler au lieu d'être
carcajou la bob bell à boston autre
animal haïssable comme le carcajou mec
qui existe dans cette région le du pack
pourtant on est des civils kilomètres
qui nous séparent mais si ça c'est c'est
le besoin en fait le ce titre de
spiritualité c'est de le besoin de
rattacher l'intangible à quelque chose
qui est concret quelque chose qui est là
qui existe et
je veux prendre un instant pour vous
demander de vous retourner des amis pour
voir qu'il ya plus de monde
c'est vrai les lois des dizaines de
milliers de personnes et je regarde
depuis tout à l'heure parlement des gens
qui étaient sur une séquence de ce
centre ville pour voir le passage
du cortège qui arrivait de l'aéroport
international jean-lesage des gens qui
pour le moins que se sont amenés ici
dans l'intervalle ce qu'il ya sur scène
mise à mort les moments où on parle de
michel lodef
non m'ayant demandé de l'applaudir c'est
ça que j'ai entendu au top le dit michel
bassi clair parce qu'elle était avec
nous
non mais il ya des représentations
culturelles qui se font sur la scène
présentement ce qu'on fait simplement
c'est qu'on informe les gens sur
différentes réalités des premiers
peuples à travers le canada mais
également mais on veut garder les gens
en haleine parce que et là vous le voyez
il ya une rencontre en ce moment qui a
cours à la résidence de la gouverneure
générale vous mettez vos lunettes à led
et moi quitte avec mary saimone en ce
moment c'est par all in le secrétaire
d'état j'ai cru voir à côté de lui pas
très loin avec des cheveux blancs
gallagher qui se monte à 1,5 à tina lys
et le responsable des relations entre
les étapes ici lui est là bas il ya
certainement à l'autre qui représente la
secrétairerie d'état donc tous toutes
les affaires générales de l'église c'est
le patron ce qu'on voyait plus tard
cette image est magnifique en soit dit
en passant de l'endroit de la résidence
le gouverneur général à québec vu
ce qu'on voit là c'est bon la photo
officielle
vous entendez les caméras qui
qui mitraille alors cette photo qui rend
officiel la visite du pape à québec et
ça peut pas être plus officiel que ça
parce que il ya le château frontenac qui
dans l'arrière-plan
mais bon parce que c'est sept ans le
père françois est rarement dans son
image son élément le plus dynamique dans
des situations comme ça oubliez on
dirait qu'ils coïncident protocole dit
qu un incident protocolaire ou alors là
est le problème unis c'est le maire
d'avrillé ya un photoshoot alors que
c'est comme ça et on l'a vu quand il est
arrivé dans l'ouest rennes où il
reconnaît un chef qui étaient là tout de
suite on a vu le jour à des fins les
lumières se sont allumées pietà
comptable il tenait la rencontre ouais
il s'est même levé pour un arbre à ses
seins et aussi on est tous dallas est
raccord de figer un peu coincé s'est
passé fort qui est moins dense offre une
image d qui me vient en tête quand est
arrivé le début de la pandémie il ya
quelqu'un qui ait pris une photo de cet
homme là qui était parti prendre une
marche dans les rues près de place saint
pierre tout seul il peut encore faire ça
il y avait toujours des rumeurs autour
de lui mais tout seul dans les rues pas
et c'est normal
ou six gardes du corps des gens
parachute ou sont ils aussi salariale en
voyage puis partent avec ses petits
serviette avec les documents d'arles je
pense que la situation la plus probante
la plus parlante j'ai pensé quand il a
en face de lui les gens quand il est
question la raison pour laquelle il y va
du je pense pas qu'il soit venu pour
être saluée par des militaires par des
remarques et la mer chose à edmonton
lors de son arrivée son visage carrément
s'est illuminé lorsque les grands chefs
sont venus le saluer lorsqu'avant soit
bon il y avait eu ou le gouverneur
général commence à se connaître
personnellement le premier ministre
toute la délégation officielle puis je
me disais bon
la réflexion que je me suis fait c'est
l'homme à 85 ans il vient de faire 12
heures d'avion probablement que ça son
principal souhait c'est d'aller se
reposer à quelque part tranquille c'est
comme cela que j'interprète est ce sa
mimique son visage et quand les grands
chefs sont arrivés
mais s'est éveillé c'est du bien c'est
est
content vous rencontrer c'est bon signe
sur l'histoire pas ça parce qu'ils
peuvent lui faire on souhaite qu'ils
soient pas venu faire ici acte 2 tomates
mon choix qui soit venu ici pour des
raisons qui sont plus d'ordre spirituel
ici c'est un coup formidable penser
autrement siphon dans lequel eric il a
17 ans à vos collègues de radio canada
là bas c'était important pour nous de
lamela au lac st tente parce que lui
aussi est on le droit de prendre soin de
lui après avoir entendu toutes nos
souffrances
depuis notre passage à rome j'ai trouvé
ça justement on est on irrespectueux des
années en particulier bas des jeunes est
aussi
important de se rappeler que d'un humain
aussi chi chi courageux de peut-être pas
dire tous les maux mais d'aller à
l'encontre peut-être de toute son équipe
qui lui dit mais pas tellement dans
disco c'est un courage aurait pu ne pas
venir du tout oui oui je te fais et je
suis ce qui est déjà très désiré
canadiens qui ne disait pas le bon
moment je crois qu'on pourrait attendre
encore quelque peu mais on a attendu
longtemps et c'est tout le monde l'a
souligné là les antiquaires
presbytérienne les oblats les soeurs de
l'assomption ce sur tout excusé tout ce
monde-là s'est excusé depuis 20 30 ou 40
ans il a fallu attendre l'année dernière
des découvertes macabres pour que la
conférence des évêques s'excuse bonne
excuse je veux bien mais alors et on
vendredi après midi oui je viens je veux
bien mais on me disait je sais pas je
pense pas que ce soit de l'eau de la
rumeur c'est plutôt des gens sincères
qui le disait le pape ne viendra pas
s'il n'est pas évités par des évêques
demandez vous pas pourquoi il n'est
jamais venu jusqu'ici c'est oui on peut
peut-être en comprendre quelque chose
l'image que vous voyez c'est toujours à
l'intérieur de la résidence officielle
de la gouverneure générale du canada
mais c'est probablement de cet endroit
que le pape va prononcer son discours
devant des représentants
oui vous voyez les passages où louis un
sage et on à monsieur alexandre
météo
je pense qu'un mec kenzy et cinq ans et
deux côtés des cardinaux
je vois wallet le croate à gauche j'ai
vu de par ma parole il est juste un côté
il est passé avec concert de quoi je
vois pas les autres mais il faut se
méfier parce qu'en diplomatie c'est pas
juste des cardinaux il ya au moins de
monseigneur je premier ministre françois
legault qui hélas oui voilà
donc ces gens là sont là je vous dirai
aux premières loges pour assister au
discours du pape franchois mais les gens
ici sur les planes aussi sont aux
premières loges parce que ce discours là
sera retransmis en direct sur les
plaines c'est pour ça que les gens sont
ici on me dit qu'il y aura le discours
du pape ne vous inquiétez pas on aura
comme à l'habitude la traduction
simultanée le pape qui ne s'exprime
qu'en espagnol c'est sa langue
maternelle
donc il y aura la traduction et la
gouverneure générale mersin amène
également qui va prononcer un discours
et ce discours sera suivi ici en direct
sur les plaines
est-ce que allez on doit s'attendre au
même processus qu'on ait fait dans
l'ouest dire dans cette première
présence en terre québécoise il va
réitérer ses excuses et ce qu'est ce
qu'on satin ce même
jeu mais de façon contraire je pense que
vous ne pensiez pas le choix ceux-ci
fallait qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils veulent
vraiment donné l'impression qu'on veut
tourner la page parce que ça ça passe
trop
pour deux sous je serais très très mal
alors je pense qu'il était au point de
départ quelqu'un qui semblait dire avant
même de parler de réconciliation parce
que je trouvais que c'était même à la
limite un peu indécent de parler si
brusquement de réconciliation et de
pardon mais je trouvais qu'on n'était
plus dans la reconnaissance de l'acte i
s'est passé quelque chose c'est son
premier as première on me dit c'est ça
et ensuite parce que c'était au niveau
où l'accès tania je trouvais que c'était
plus proche de la guérison l'eau les
miracles de l'eau c'est tellement
important
il ya un prêtre que vous ayez l'eau pour
les pour les premiers peuples c'est la
guérison c'est la purification et la
tomate de manas au serbe qui vont couler
la dalle n'est y était vrai il y avait
une infraction le kit est belle
honnêtement c'était bout peut-être
je tirais dans la gradation alors on est
peut-être passé de la reconnaissance la
guérison aujourd'hui de quoi sera-t-il
là il arrive au québec et leurs épaules
les mêmes représentants des premières
nations qui sont là ce ne sont pas les
mêmes peuples ce n'est pas la même
réalité donc en principe il doit
demander vous demander pardon et quand
je dis ça je regardais michèle audette
comme il le fait pour les premières
nations dans le west power qui était je
vous dirais l'ouest de l'ontario me
disait vous verrez demain telle
reconnaissance québec guérison début du
chemin et ical ou et l'espoir autrement
dit alors juste dire on reconnaît qu'on
s'arrête là où beaucoup comme étant si
on te fait un bout de chemin au peu de
temps faire un petit bout de chou mais
aussi là je pense qu il faut qu il ya
quelque chose faut qu'elle sorte de
gradation faut qu'il nous dise quelque
chose de plus qu'il nous a déjà dit le
10 ans est légèrement loose badge peut
partir maintenant c'était pour eux mêmes
mais j'adore d'attali si vous permettez
alain je peux comprendre s'arrêter
peut-être normal de proposer cette
logique là mais pensons à ceux qui ont
même pas écouté des paroles du pape
parce qu'ils sont dans une communauté un
certain âge qu'on les a amenés ici ils
ont peut-être pas senti l'évolution le
changement à chaque tour
ange passe pour ça qu'il ya des
représentants des premières nations
quand même
trois mois j'aurais pu vivre un beau
duel
droite pour vous non l'appropriation
savez quoi là je me permets en attendant
que le pape arrive je me permets de vous
dire que
le moment où il s'adressera à ses
évêques c'est peut-être là qu'on aura la
marche à suivre
croyez vous c'est peut-être lui qui va
passer ses messages
bon les messages que certains espèrent
de dire aux diocèses partout au canada
là les causes on va s'organiser pour
régler ça comme les fêlés l'église unie
c est ce que si un moment où ils
pourraient le faire ce soir là ces
domaines et demain soir support pourquoi
pas à céret souvenez vous d'un truc qui
s'est passé c'est écrit dans le succès
de ce produit il ya deux avocats qui
font une conférence de presse avant que
le pape n'arrive et ils sont
responsables tous les deux je ne sais
plus combien de recours que les six ans
d'histoire de prêter deux fils et que
distille existants aux pattes sortez
votre équipe pour ça qu'ils disent
monsieur le pape pourriez-vous dire à
ses ouailles de bouger et voilà parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'ils prennent leur
temps nous nous les gens qu'on
représente moeurs et voilà et y perdre
l'accès à une justice minimale alors est
ce que c'est ce que le pape aurait envie
peut-être de dire ces expulsés tout le
monde parle des archives on parle du
territoire on parle de ces choses là ce
que ce qu'ils auraient l'audace jeu
j'essaie de deviner ce qu'il aurait
l'audace de dire à son clergé la rue
maintenant de le moment maintenant on a
reconnu ouais maintenant elle l'aurait
pas les deux passent à l'action je suis
un mouvement important demain demain
soir eh oui oui mais la mer sa sainte
anne de beaupré en israël on va vous la
présente en direct mes deux mains jouant
alors qui se dressera ses évêques montre
savez vous qui est capable de durer avec
son tour oui un atout
très généralement il fait des souhaits
de noël inquiète surtout les parents
font sourire surtout son clergé
cardinaux et compagnie et il les a
sermonnés l'ami les uns savané à l'ogs
leur prenons sensibilise à ceux ci
achètent écoliers de pêcher épouvantable
et c'était dans le sens de ma maman et
c'est un peu ce que dit hier l'accès
aux essais faut cesser de défendre à
tout prix l'institution faut commencer à
chercher la vérité merci oui ah voilà
c'était pas voilà c'est passé
complètement inaperçu moi j'ai accroché
aussi là dessus nous prépares tu as
demain où il pourrait être
il ya un point puis quand on sait on a
discuté ensemble au téléjournal keita
qui adoptent quelques jours
[Musique]
on va envoyer les pilleurs ont rongé par
la question que j'avais pour vous le
grand officier prendre des photos selon
partager avec vous dans les jours à
venir je vous demande donc de ne pas
prendre des photos ou des vidéos pendant
la cérémonie
maintenant veuillez s'il vous plaît vous
assurer que vos téléphones sont éteints
nous comprenons qu aujourd'hui que c'est
une journée difficile pour certains
d'entre vous veuillez noter que nous
avons des travailleurs de soutien en
santé mentale prêt à aider les invités
qui en ont besoin
avant de commencer j'aimerais présenter
monsieur alexandre mais kenzy de matinée
couchent chaque film qui jouera le
tambour pour l'arrivée de sa sainteté et
son excellence merci à tous
je vais aujourd'hui
animé cette cérémonie dans certaines
disciplines autre photographe officiel
va prendre des photographies et celles
ci seront partagées dans les jours à
venir je vous demande donc de ne pas
prendre de photos de vidéos pendant la
cérémonie je vous demande également de
bien vouloir éteindre le téléphone
cellulaire
nous le comprenons pour certains d'entre
vous aujourd'hui peut-être une journée
défi difficile nous avons des personnes
prêtes à vous aider dans le domaine de
la santé mentale je présente à temps
alexandre mackenzie deux matinées coffee
shops ville qui va jouer du tambour
pendant que nous donnons l'avenue la
bienvenue à sa sainteté je vous invite à
vous l'avez si vous le pouvez pour
l'accueillir sa sainteté le pape
françois leur excellence et le premier
ministre
à eelv a eu du tout que vous invite à
vous lever si vous le pouvez pour donner
la bienvenue à au saint père
à son excellence
la gouverneure générale et au premier
ministre
[Musique]
non
gemma
[Musique]
enesco
mathé
k
c'est ma
atteint
ah non
[Musique]
chez madame
maniema
e
ap
ça
chez moi 2
[Musique]
jdo alors bienvenue
alors un jour de chocolat b blue ocean
par
chinois tôt les genôts présentés chez
autochtones indiens venus acheter
chamonix
maintenant je vous demanderais si
nous
essayons de parler de s'écouter à
chambre partagée à chante importe vos
croyances peu importe la religion
souvenir d'avoir rappelé également donné
j'aimerais choc on prend une minute
heure de silence et ne déclenche gardons
le méchant pour les gens partout et même
quand tu es perdu pour les gens afin
qu'on n'a jamais retrouvé
j'aimerais charles
merci
merci comment je remercie tout le monde
au nom de leurs excellences la très
honorable mairie stein et monsieur 8
fraser je vous souhaite la bienvenue à
cette cérémonie en direct
et mister freeze
couler
l'argent de croisade lignon c'est une
série apporte de la chaleur pour foyer
et aujourd'hui nous donnons la bienvenue
a réparé fils il va prendre soin de la
colique tout au long de notre cérémonie
lalande
événements importants comme la cérémonie
d'aujourd'hui cette lampe est utilisé
dans le nord pour apporter lumière et
chaleur à l'admr n'a comique
pour commencer j'aimerais inviter les
n'est vraiment pour lui de la première
nation huronne wendat a prononcé des
mots de bienvenue at elle dit raymond
gros louis a de longue date kristen
stewart
on va rester
assis
patron je vais vous demander quelque
chose de spécial
ça va avec la la pandémie qui s'est
passé il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
changé dans nos cérémonies et on n'a pas
le choix de s'adapter et à
j'aimerais ça que quand je vois commencé
à
allumer la sauge et fait un mort lié
avec lesquels direction
et avant je veux aller porter au pub
france-soir
fois l'odeur et à une pleine de dindes
sauvages qui est un animal de survie
pour les bandas tzu territoire donc je
voir m c'est plus mais ce foin d'odeur
le foin d'audace et il va servir le tas
de problèmes il vaut purifiée par le lot
de rang
donc je sais que le pas françois un peu
de musique avec à fumer donc il y en
aura beaucoup de façons de faire une
cérémonie de s'adapter et je pense que
c'est important que pas françois
reçoivent ce foin d'odeur là et c'est
une loi pour participer en même temps au
smad ou quatre directions
avant je vais en présentant wendat et à
quoi joue et innovation
on y entre on
châtie andy chaaouane oui chez piémont
vous lui chelsea
analyse -
wendat and i want d'accueil indoor et ça
fait pas longtemps que j'ai appris a
réappris maroc je ne sais pas au complet
mais le voleur de ne présenter à pour
moi c'est beaucoup parce que quand que
je me présente à ma langue je parle pas
juste à mon nom mais on a de tout âge
toute ma nation complet donc je m'en
vais lever le voile et porter un
non pas françois je viens d'un sauvage
sur la présence très importante pour nos
deux nations
vont vous mettre le point nodal puisse
être un très bon
pour la santé
[Musique]
bonjour
je
[Musique]
et envers le cercle virtuel
savez avec la vendée mis un viol les
petits vidéos le concert
je m'étais aperçu que même si on répond
à présentiel on peut faire des choses à
partir de l'esprit et on va ouvrir un
cercle ici aujourd'hui à partir de
l'esprit
et à partir de ce cercle on va
visualiser un peu ça qui
parce que le feu sacré a unit tous y
existe dans la création
donc on va mettre du thabor virtuel où
six d'entre eux
et en même temps on va honorer à
des quintés l'image vidéo à l'eau le feu
l'air la terre
on voit en aurait aussi l'aspect
minéral
végétal
et humain
je vois demandé à la direction de l'ess
d'ouvrir sa porte
ou qu'on puisse avoir accès à cette
direction j'en demandais à direction du
sud d'ouvrir cette porte aussi pour
avoir accès à sa direction il faut
demander à direction l'ouest
d'ouvrir cette porte la porte de
grammaire
on voit honoré adressons au delà la
direction
des grands part mais aussi je vais
toujours une direction spéciale pour les
alouettes
parce qu'ils sont à une minorité dans
une d'opter dès fois on a tendance à
l'oublier mais un portail ou parfaire
mais je contacte alors commencé avec un
clic que je connais aussi donc c'est un
honneur d'avoir les genoux était d'avoir
cette culture là ou si un matin
et joie ouvrira les quatre sélections un
faux frère moss fait quatre fois c'est
un os de dindes sauvages que j'ai eus
blandin tant d'années que je veux faire
damer cérémonie
et avant de de faire j'aimerais ça que
vous mettez votre minceur chao chacun
le car ça peut servir le breton parole
au matin mais c'est là que le créateur a
mis la sagesse ou humain et endroits
souvent allé se rappeler ce geste
important djiar de justement aller se
connecter à 7 à 7,5 geste
demandera grand-mère de l'ouest
de nous devrons d'accès rouge en serre
sacré en eau des esprits
pour qu'ils puissent rejoindre avec nous
ou qu'on soit déjà unit est plus fort
sans
témoin
sans repas gras par françois
j'aimerais maintenant éviter le très
honorable justin trudeau a prononcé
quelques mots en vaille que vaille dans
l'aube du statut d'outsider
jersey n'est
vraiment
dirigeants autochtones le très saint
père excellence premier ministre legault
je suis très heureux d'être ici avec
vous aujourd'hui est de pouvoir dire
quelques mots d'introduction
je tiens d'abord à remercier les
premières nations qui ont fréquenté et
occuper ce territoire pendant des
millénaires pour leur accueil sur leur
territoire traditionnel et de traiter
les we welcome to win je suis à l'heure
où nous accueillons sa sainteté cette
semaine il est important de réfléchir
sur l'importance de ce moment pour les
survivants pour les peuples autochtones
et pour toute la population canadienne
juillet c'était la fête de sainte anne
sainte anne c'est une figure importante
pour les catholiques elle représente
l'amour maternel
elle représente aussi la famille la
famille si nos racines c'est ce qui nous
a aidé à grandir et à découvrir le monde
et la famille
c'est la première chose qui a été rendu
aux enfants qui ont été envoyés dans les
pensionnats autochtones
quand j'ai visité de kamloops kawas et
williams lake
quand je parle avec les survivants et
avec les familles je pense aux enfants
et je pense aussi aux parents
à ce stade
en tant que manager je ne peux pas
m'imaginer qu'on m'enlève mes enfants
quand les enfants pleurent je peux les
consoler quand ils sont heureux je
voudrais partager ce sentiment de joie
et de rires c'est avec eux mais dans les
pensionnats pour autochtones ces enfants
étaient seuls s'était isolé dans la
souffrance et la peine loin de leurs
familles leurs communautés et ce qui est
encore pire ils étaient privés de leur
langue de leur culture
leur identité
une solitude profonde une perte non
seulement de familles et de communautés
mais de leur langue leur culture
et leur identité
depuis la publication en 2015 du rapport
final de la commission de vérité et
réconciliation les premières nations les
inuits et limites y demande au parc de
présenter des excuses aux survivants à
leurs familles et aux communautés
les excuses pour le rôle que l'église
catholique romaine comme institution a
joué dans les mauvais traitements sur
les plans spirituel
culturel
émotionnels physiques
et sexuels que les enfants autochtones
ou subie dans les pensionnats dirigées
par l'église
l'événement de cette semaine un moss
kouachi ce n'aurait pas été possible
sans le courage et la persévérance
les survivants qui ont partagé leurs
souvenirs douloureux et raconter leurs
expériences
incluant directement aux saveurs humains
nioro et 9 ans
privé de compétition à l'occasion de
conversations précédente et depuis la
première fois que nous avons abordé
cette question vous m'avez toujours
accorder le temps
vraiment cherché à comprendre à faire le
bien et à réparer oui cette semaine vous
avez reconnu les sévices que les
premières nations ont suivi dans les
pensionnats pour autochtones et qui ont
entraîné la destruction de leur culture
des pertes de vie et les traumatismes
qu'ils éprouvent encore dans toutes les
régions du pays la mesure où comme votre
sainteté l'a déclaré hamas croisic les
excuses ne sont pas un point final elle
constitue seulement la première étape un
point de départ
lundi matin et se dénouent assis au
milieu deux survivantes je les ai vus
réagir à vos excuses où chacun et
trouvera ce dont il a besoin global mais
il ne fait aucun doute que vous aurez eu
un énorme impact
les survivances de leurs descendants
devront désormais être au centre de tout
ce que nous ferons ensemble pour donner
une chance le chef national des dénés
gérald antoine qui était au vatican en a
pris le dernier a comparé ce moment à ce
qu'il a ressenti lorsque en marchant
dans la neige il a reconnu les traces
toute fraîche d'un orignal de l'espoir
aujourd'hui j'aimerais dire
continuons tous à travailler ensemble
afin de garder cet espoir en vie quand
je suis allé au vatican il ya cinq ans
maintenant j'y étais pour aborder le
sujet des pensionnats et de la
réconciliation avec votre sainteté et je
sais que votre présence ici cette
semaine
n'aurait pas été possible sans vos
convictions personnelles et votre
intégrité
merci d'être venu avec le coeur ouvert
on reconnaît tout ce
que le système des pensionnats a tenté
d'assimiler les enfants autochtones
aujourd'hui les peuples autochtones
continuent de se battre pour défendre et
préserver leur culture et leur langue
rassemblement traditionnel qu'ils aient
lieu à mars coach en est un très bon
exemple
la réconciliation c'est notre
responsabilité
à nous tous c'est notre responsabilité
de voir nos différences non pas comme un
obstacle mais comme une occasion
d'apprendre de mieux nous comprendre et
de passer à l'action
elle dit que la réconciliation n'est pas
un geste unique view mais un cheminement
de guérison qui dure toute la vie c'est
un cheminement différent pour chaque
quinzaine j'ai parlé de sainte anne
était le symbole de l'amour maternel et
de la famille mais sans talent c'est
aussi un symbole de guérison mon
demain après sa sainteté visiteurs à
sainte anne de beaupré
les pèlerins s'y rend depuis des siècles
pour prier et pour demander à sainte
anne de les aider à guérir
alors dans cet esprit de guérison
n'abandonnons jamais un jeu les
canadiens les institutions ensemble
continuons à travailler aux côtés des
peuples autochtones
jusqu'à ce que nous réussissions à
construire un avenir meilleur pour
chacun
merci thank you gracias
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le premier ministre
l'équipe rolling stone j'invite son
excellence la très honorable mairie sans
même gouverneur général du canada à
prendre la parole
awana aulas
bonjour
allô
bonjour bas la prime tout ça coûte on le
sac ou de coin coin
pour tous et sans doute et je vous
souhaite la baie de new hâlas celle de
dell
wacom
votre sainteté dans la citadelle de
québec mon mari et moi même sommes
honorés de vous accueillir et de avoir
parmi les noms des survivants des
ennemis des leaders des gardiens du
savoir des diplômes à la comédie ni
terre
d'anciens commissaires de la commission
de vérité et réconciliation est ainsi
que tous ceux qui nous regardent d'un
océan à l'autre et à l'autre je tiens à
remercier les membres des premières
nations qui occupent le territoire
depuis les militaires
pour leur accueil sur leurs terres
traditionnelles ou visé par un traité
de vous nous écoutez présentement si l
acide l eau à l'heure au canada vous est
ce un territoire autochtone il est
important de reprendre conscience
je vous remercie d'avoir fait cette
visite au canada dans le cadre de ce que
vous appelez votre pèlerinage de
pénitence nous sommes ici rassemblés
dans cette citadelle historique un lieu
de partage d'histoire et des échanges
d'idées
avec cette visite nous envoyer un signal
au monde vous et l'église catholique
romaine marcher avec nous sur les
chemins de la réconciliation de la
guérison de l'espoir et du renouveau
tout cela a commencé avec masques oasis
où nous avons été témoins de deux
réalités la première la souffrance la
douleur des survivants
des membres des communautés qui ont
souffert quand dd ni les peuples
autochtones qui ont été soumis à des
politiques qui voulaient éliminer leur
culture leur langue ainsi que leur
croyance des pratiques spirituelles
des survivants qui chaque jour portent
le traumatisme des pensionnats pour
autochtones
mais
ces personnes ces survivants il défie
toutes les étiquettes ce sont des
parents qui ont défendu leurs enfants
quand personne d'autre ne le faisait ce
sont des défenseurs qui se sont battus
et se battent encore pour leur langue et
leur culture
afin qu'elles puissent s'épanouir pour
les générations à venir ce sont des
artistes qui transportent leur histoire
à travers leur musique leurs danses leur
culture et leur langue ils sont tous
fiers
tous déterminé
votre sainteté ils sont venus vous
écouter avec le coeur et l'esprit ouvert
certains prêts à pardonner d'autres
vivent encore avec la souffrance mais
tous prêts à écouter chacun d'entre eux
souhaitent progresser dans son
cheminement vers la guérison
[Musique]
continue de nous montrer
que malgré les défis
auxquels ils peuvent être confrontés
et aux les affronter avec dignité et une
grande détermination
je
salue
ce que les communautés autochtones ont
accompli au cours de cette semaine ce
sont les peuples autochtones qui ont
travaillé qui ont patienté et qui ont
prié pour obtenir des excuses
officielles sur les terres autochtones
du canada
ils n'ont jamais abandonné
souvenons nous que c'est grâce à leur
courage à l'heure ayant ce que nous
sommes ici aujourd'hui
votre sainteté leurs efforts font du
canada une nation plus forte
et se rattraper ah oui mana à acro pit
nous narre après si manu et kanata mais
nos parcs piscines matin
et désir collectif prix du zinc ont
collectivement de perpétuer le souvenir
des événements survenus dans les
pensionnats de raconter les histoires
des survivantes fait de ceux et celles
qui ne sont jamais rentrés chez eux
ainsi que de soutenir et de prendre soin
de ceux qui ont pu le faire les soutenir
en leur offrant des ressources en santé
mentale était les familles découvrir le
véritable sort de ceux qui ne sont
jamais rentrés à la maison et prendre
soin des membres des peuples autochtones
qui ont besoin de temps et des espaces
pour comprendre la portée de cette
visite et les mesures à entreprendre par
la suite votre sainteté comme vous
l'avait indiqué il s'agit d'une étape
importante vers un dialogue et des
actions supplémentaires qui mèneront à
une véritable réconciliation
en effet nous avons hâte de connaître
les actions qui seront prises par
l'église pour poursuivre ce travail
essentiel lundi vous avez visité
l'église du sacré coeur des premiers
peuples à edmonton vous y avez déclaré
que la réconciliation est une grâce qui
doit être ne m'en d
j'ajouterai à cela que la réconciliation
est une grâce qui s'acquiert
par un travail soutenu et une
compréhension mutuelle
ce travail incombe à chacun et à chacune
d'entre nous c'est notre responsabilité
sacrée
pour toute chose nous sommes prêts in
canada de respect la monarchie un
changement monumental s'opère dans notre
façon de penser dans l'histoire et la
conscience collective de notre pays le
moment est propice à la démarche de
réconciliation
alors que nous abordons cette en jeu
ainsi que la santé et le bien-être futur
des communautés autochtones je me tourne
vers chacun et chacune d'entre nous pour
promouvoir la grée guérison en imams uk
tout guérir ma musique ne m'a mis sarthe
nick est un trajet et non une
destination il faut du temps ça commence
lentement doucement prudemment la
guérison suit son propre chemin nous
faisons avancer mais nous menons aussi
dans de nombreuses autres directions
et un projet et non une destination il
faut deux timbres se commence lentement
d'oslo heureusement
la guérison suit son propre chemin
nous fait avancer mais nous mais là
aussi dans de nombreuses autres actions
eva joly il est la guérison fini par
dépasser l'impuissance la colère ou la
douleur la guérison nous permet de
surmonter les traumatismes
la guérison à vivre ravive notre santé
mentale spirituelle et physique j'ai été
témoin de ce processus j'ai vu le
processus de guérison se réaliser grâce
à l'art à l'esprit de communauté à la
bienveillance à la générosité et à la
rave revitalisation de la langue de la
culture et de l'identité
votre sainteté je sais que même après
votre départ du canada vous continuerez
à vous intéresser non seulement aux
défis et aux souffrances de ces
communautés mais aussi à leur fierté
d'autochtones à leur résilience et à
leur contribution au canada et au monde
entier
ramener ses histoires avec vous partager
les parts ou et continuer à trouver des
moyens de collaborer de tendre la main
de guérir nos communautés
ce que j'ai vu jusqu'à présent au cours
de cette visite me remplit d'espoir le
canada a hâte de travailler avec le
saint-siège sur la réconciliation
ainsi que sur de nombreux autres
changements de dieu et urgents comme la
promotion de la paix de l'éducation
l'élimination des barrières la lutte
contre la pauvreté les maladies et le
rétablissement de la confiance je vous
remercie de vos efforts merci à tous les
canadiens d'avoir entendu et répondu à
l'appel de la réconciliation à verser
les canadiennes d'avoir en 32e et roy
pando l'appel à la reconsolidation
kanatami ali malek la caméra de sharon
la racine à la parade shiloh dahmane la
a4 cagliari a amené books new york
thuram est mort at any two pictures guy
legault
your highness
les meilleurs voeux vous accompagne dans
votre pèlerinage que le créateur nous
bénisse tous merci mais luigi nago
revenir
[Applaudissements]
chargé par françois et a partagé son
discours à prendre la parole
épi
si
madame la gouverneure générale minutes
monsieur le premier ministre
et bien des autorités civiles et
religieuses
des représentants des peuples
autochtones murmure excellence membre du
board de matteo lice mesdames et
messieurs le salon colbert min et je
vous salue cordialement les salaires et
je remercie m madame
et monsieur justin trudeau pour leur
parole et marc ont placé mais je suis
heureux de m'adresser
à vous à qui incombe la responsabilité
de servir les habitants de seine est un
pays immense et des malheurs d'un océan
à l'autre
ce pays nous offre un patrimoine naturel
écrit hors délai
parmi ses nombreuses beautés me viennent
à l'esprit c'est vaste et spectaculaire
forêt d'érable qui donne aux paysages
canadiens sa singularité et ses tons
chatoyants
permettez que je m'inspire du symbole
par excellence de ses terres la feuille
d'érable depuis les armoiries de québec
celle ci s'est rapidement diffusée
jusqu'à devenir l'emblème placé au coeur
du drapeau canadien
certes ce phénomène est assez récent
les érables eux sont les gardiens de la
mémoire de bien des générations passées
bien avant l'arrivée des colons sur ses
terres du canada
les peuples autochtones en extrayait la
sève avec laquelle ils préparaient des
sirops nourrissant et l'on pense alors à
leur travail acharné toujours attaché à
sauvegarder la terre et l'environnement
est toujours fidèle à une vision
harmonieuse de la création c'est à dire
celle d'un livre ouvert
qui enseigne aux hommes comment aimer le
créateur et comment vivre en symbiose
avec les autres êtres vivants
il ya ici de riches enseignements
comment écouter dieu les personnes la
nature des enseignements plus nécessaire
que jamais dans le frénétique tourbillon
du monde actuel marqué par une
accélération constante
celle-ci entrave l'émergence d'un
développement véritablement humain
durable et intégrale cela finit par
produire une société de fatigue août et
de désillusions une société qui se bat
pour redécouvrir le goût de la
contemplation le parfum véritable des
relations humaines la mystique de
lettres en totalité
comme nous en avons besoin de nous
écouter de dialoguer pour nous dégager
de l'individualisme régnant des
jugements hâtifs
de l'agressivité sans réserve de la
tentation de diviser le monde entre les
bons et les mauvais jours les grandes
feuilles de l'érable absorbe l'air
contaminé et en retour nous donne de
l'oxygène elle nous invite à nous
émerveiller de la beauté de la création
à nous laisser emporter par les valeurs
saines des cultures autochtones
elles sont pour nous tous une source
d'inspiration
et elle pourrait nous aider à l'heure de
guérir nos penchants néfaste à
l'exploitation
exploiter la création mais aussi
exploiter les relations et le temps
orienter l'activité humaine uniquement
en termes d'utilité et de bénéfices
et pourtant
c'est le sont vitales ont fait par le
passé face à une violente opposition
tous particulièrement avec les
politiques d'assimilation et
d'affranchissement qui comprenait le
système des pensionnats pour autochtones
celles ci ont blessé tant de familles
autochtones
dévaloriser leur langue leur culture
leur vision du monde
dans ce système déplorable défendue par
les autorités gouvernementales de
l'époque un système qui a séparé tant
d'enfants de leur famille dans ce
système plusieurs institutions
catholiques locales ont été impliqués
pour cela j'exprime ma honte et ma
douleur
et aux côtés des évêques de ce pays
je réitère ma demande de pardon pour le
mal commis par tant de chrétiens contre
les peuples autochtones
pour tout cela je demande par
les tragiques
quand certains croyants comme cela s'est
produit durant cette période de
l'histoire ne se conforme pas à
l'évangile mais aux convenances de ce
monde
si la foi chrétienne a joué un rôle
essentiel dans la composition des idéaux
les plus hauts du canada
caractérisée par le désir de construire
un pays meilleur pour tous ses habitants
il est nécessaire d'admettre ses propres
erreurs et de nous engager ensemble a
réalisé un objectif que je sais que vous
partagez tous
promouvoir les droits légitimes de tous
les peuples autochtones et favoriser des
processus de guérison et de
réconciliation
entre eux et les nonnes octobre tonnes
de ce pays
voilà qui est reflété dans votre
engagement à répondre de façon adéquate
aux appels à l'action de la commission
de vérité et réconciliation sur et aussi
dans votre attention à reconnaître les
droits des peuples autochtones
le saint siège et les communautés
catholiques locales ont la volonté
concrète
de promouvoir les cultures autochtones
selon des chemin spirituel spécifique et
approprié
ceux ci doivent comprendre le souci de
leurs traditions culturelles leurs
coutumes leurs langues leurs processus
éducatif propres et ce dans l'esprit de
la déclaration des nations unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones
nous désirons renouveler la relation
entre l'église et les peuples
autochtones du canada
cette relation est marquée par un amour
qui a porté deux grands fruits mais
aussi malheureusement par des blessures
que nous nous efforçons de comprendre et
de guérir
je suis très reconnaissant d'avoir pu
connaître et entendre divers
représentants des peuples autochtones
durant ces derniers mois à rome je suis
aussi reconnaissant de pouvoir
consolider ici les belles relations que
nous avons commencé à établir le mot
mendoze
des moments nous avons vécu ensemble
ont laissé en moi une trace
ils m'ont aussi laissé la volonté ferme
de répondre à l'indignation et à la
honte que provoque en moi la souffrance
endurée par les peuples autochtones en
suivant un chemin fraternelle et patient
avec tous les canadiens en accord avec
la vérité et la justice
en recherchant ensemble la guérison et
la réconciliation
toujours animé par l'espérance il cette
histoire de douleur et de mépris issue
d'une mentalité colonisatrice ne se
guérit pas facilement
mais elle nous rappelle aussi que la
colonisation ne s'arrête pas
elle se transforme en fête en certains
lieux se déguisent et se dissimule
il en est ainsi pour les colonisations
idéologique
autrefois la mentalité colonialiste à
négliger la vie concrète des personnes
elle imposait des modèles culturels
préétabli
aujourd'hui encore les colonisations et
des logiques ne manquent pas qui oppose
qui s'opposent à cette réalité de
l'existence et étouffent l'attachement
naturel aux valeurs des tables et qui
essaie dans des racines et les
traditions l'histoire et les liens
religieux
c'est une mentalité qui suppose avoir
dépassé les pages sombres de l'histoire
est faite ainsi place à ce qu'on appelle
la culture cansell la culture de
l'annulation qui évalue le passé
uniquement sur la base de certaines
catégories actuelles et ainsi vient une
mode culturel qui uniformise qui rend
toutes identiques qui ne tolère pas les
différences
ne se concentre que sur l'instant
présent sur les besoins et les droits
des individus et qui négligent vient
souvent les devoirs envers les plus
faibles les plus fragiles mieux les
pauvres les migrants les personnes âgées
les malades les enfants à naître
ce sont les oubliés de la société du
bien-être ce sont eux qui dans
l'indifférence générale sont jetés comme
une poignée de feuilles mortes dans
l'âtre de leur
union
par ailleurs les cimes multicolores
riche des arbres taira le nom rappelle
qu'il est important de tenir compte de
l'ensemble est de favoriser des
communautés humaines n'ont pas uniforme
mais réellement ouverte et inclusive
comme chaque feuille est indispensable à
l'enrichissement de ses cimes
chaque famille chaque cellule
essentielle de la société
doit être valorisée ou tout simplement
parce que l'avenir de l'humanité passe
par la famille déjà la rumeur réalisa
sociale conclut elle est la première
réalité sociale concrète mais elle est
néanmoins menacé par de nombreux
facteurs violence domestique
frénésie de la vie professionnelle
mentalité individualiste simplement
carriérisme effréné chômage sur la
solitude des jeunes et l'abandon des
personnes âgées des malades
les peuples autochtones ont beaucoup à
nous apprendre au sujet de la
conversation et de la protection de la
famille ni puisque déjà à l'enfant ils
apprennent à reconnaître ce qui est bien
et ce qui est mal à dire la vérité à
partager à corriger les torts à
recommencer à se réconforter et à se
réconcilier
il me souffle il que les sévices subis
par les peuples autochtones
dont nous avons aujourd'hui
nous servent de mise en garde à vue
afin que l'on n'oublie jamais le soin et
les droits de la famille ou non
d'éventuelles exigences de production
sûrs et d'intérêts individuels
alors mais revenons-en à la feuille
d'érable
en temps de guerre les soldats sont
servait pour penser guérir les blessures
oui aujourd'hui des couleurs face à la
folie insensé de la guerre mais
il nous faut de nouveaux apaiser les
extrémismes de l'opposition
et soigner les blessures de la haine ou
l'interview un témoin de violences
tragiques passé a dit récemment qu'elle
a parce que la paix à son secret non non
jamais haïr qui que ce soit vu qu'ils
lui si l'on veut vivre il ne faut jamais
haïr nécessite un monde nous n'avons pas
besoin de diviser le monde en a mis en
ennemi
de prendre les distances et de nour et
armés jusqu'aux dents
ni la course aux armements unis les
stratégies de dissuasion nous
n'apporterons la paix et la sécurité ont
agi au monde il ne faut pas s'interroger
sur la façon de continuer à faire la
guerre mais plutôt comment y mettre fin
il faut empêcher que les peuples soient
de nouveau prise en otage par par
d'effrayantes guerre froide qui ne cesse
de s'étendre
nous avons besoin de politiques créative
et prévoyant que c'est parce qu'ils
sachent sortir des schémas des partis
pour apporter des réponses aux défis
mondiaux
en effet les grands enjeux actuels qu'il
s'agit de la paix des changements
climatiques des effets de la pandémie ou
encore des migrations internationales
ont une constante en commun
ils sont mondiaux
ce sont des défis mondiaux des enjeux
mondiaux qui nous affecte tous
si tous parlent de la nécessité de tenir
compte d'un ensemble la politique ne
peut rester prisonnière d'intérêts
partisans
il faut savoir regarder comme
l'enseignent la cg sagesse autochtones
des sept générations futures et non pas
les convenances immédiat les échéances
électorales le soutien des groupes de
pression les valoriser aussi les désirs
de fraternité de justice et de paix de
ces jeunes générations si
comme il faut écouter les personnes
âgées pour retrouver la mémoire et la
sagesse il faut embrasser les rêves des
jeunes pour assurer un élan et un avenir
et je sais mais ces derniers ces jeunes
méritent un avenir meilleur que celui
que nous leur préparons
il mérite d'être impliqué dans les choix
visant à construire le présent mais
aussi l'avenir en particulier à souffle
sauvegarder la maison commune pour
laquelle les valeurs et les
enseignements des peuples autochtones
sont précieux mais huta dira à ce propos
je tiens à saluer l'engagement louable
en faveur de l'environnement à l'échelon
local
on pourrait presque dire d'ailleurs que
les emblèmes inspirées de la nature
comme le lis sur le drapeau de la
province du québec ou encore la feuille
d'érable sur celui du canada confirme la
vocation écologique de ce pays
la commission comme on y est lorsque la
commission spéciale a été amené à
évaluer les milliers de maquettes envoyé
pour la création du drapeau national
donc beaucoup trop venait d'ailleurs de
gens ordinaires
à sa surprise
presque toutes contenait précisément la
représentation de la feuille d'érable
la participation autour de ce symbole
partager m'amène à souligner un mot
essentiel pour les canadiens
le multiculturalisme est à la base de la
cohésion du lien social il est à la base
de la cohésion d'une société aussi
composite que les couleurs variées des
cimes des
la même feuille d'érable avec sa
multiplicité de pointe et de bord fait
penser à une figure poli et de riz et
l'indic que vous êtes un peuple capable
d'inclure afin que ceux qui arrivent
puisse trouver une place dans cette
unité multiforme et apporter leur
contribution originale
le multiculturalisme présente un défi
permanent celui d'acteur et d'embrasser
les différentes composantes en présence
tout en respectant la diversité de leurs
traditions et de leurs cultures souvent
sans supposer que le processus est
terminé une fois pour toutes
et tous un pigeon les jours je salue à
cet égard la générosité de l'accueil que
vous avez réservé aux nombreux migrants
ukrainien et afghans
mais vous devez aussi travaillé pour
dépasser la rhétorique de la peur des
immigrés in arms est vraiment leur
donner l'occasion selon vos moyens a
conclu de s'impliquer de manière
responsable dans la société
pour ce faire les droits et la
démocratie s'impose
mais il faut aussi s'attaquer à la
mentalité individualiste
et rappeler que la vie en commun il
repose sur des principes que le système
politique ne peut concevoir tout seul
tous les lundis là aussi la culture
autochtone s'avère particulièrement
utile puisqu'elle rappelle l'importance
des valeurs de la socialisation tout
comme l'église catholique qui grâce à sa
dimension universelle aux soins qu'elles
apportent aux plus fragiles au service
mais j'estime en faveur de la vie
humaine et ce à toutes les étapes de la
conception jusqu'à la mort naturelle est
heureuse d'offrir sa contribution
ces jours ci
j'ai entendu parler de nombreuses
personnes dans le besoin qui frappent
aux portes des paroles nous sommes même
dans un pays aussi développé et avancé
que le canada qui accorde beaucoup
d'attention à l'assistante sociale
nombreux sont des sans abri qui compte
sur les églises et sur les banques
alimentaires
recevoir aide et réconfort essentiels
qui ne le verront pas ne sont pas
seulement d'ordre matériel
ses frères et ses soeurs nous amène à
considérer mme urgence
de travailler pour corriger les
injustices radical qui polluent notre
monde et qui font que la ronde à
l'abondance des dons de la création est
répartie de manière beaucoup trop inégal
alors il est scandaleux que le bien-être
générés par le développement économique
qui ne profite pas à tous les secteurs
de la société
les il est triste que ce soit
précisément chez les autochtones que
l'on relève souvent
beaucoup de taux de pauvreté ainsi que
d'autres indicateurs négatifs
tels que le faible taux de scolarisation
et d'accès difficile au logement et à
l'assistance sanitaire alors fut
l'emblème de la feuille d'érable qui
apparaît habituellement sur les
étiquettes des produits du pays
encourager tout un chacun à faire des
choix économiques et sociaux visant au
partage et au soin des personnes dans le
besoin
solo c'est uniquement en travaillant
ensemble et d'un commun accord
que l'on affronte les défis urgents
d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui d'un lieu je vous remercie
de votre hospitalité de votre attention
pim et de votre estime une houle est
conçu le jeu tiens à vous dire avec une
affection sincère
que le canada et ses habitants me
tiennent vraiment à coeur merci
[Applaudissements]
merci monde de l'art excellence je tiens
à vous remercier tous pour votre
présence aujourd'hui pour terminer la
cérémonie les violonistes à lestiac les
applaudissements que vous avez entendu
tout à l'heure sont ceux qui provenaient
de la salle où le discours a été
prononcé mais il y en a eu également des
plus moi je vais vous dire timide ici
sur les plaines d'abraham la fin de ce
discours bord fait c'est très large
comme discours alain crevier m'avait dit
c'est typiquement lui ce discours là bon
je vous le régime là dès le départ il a
parlé de l'enseignement spirituel que
nous pouvons obtenir de la nature en
faisant le parallèle avec la présence de
fleurs de lys sur le drapeau du québec
la présence de la feuille d'érable sur
le drapeau du canada il aurait réitéré
sa demande de pardon pour le mal causé
par tant de chrétiens c'est ainsi qu'il
l'a a présenté aujourd'hui il le dit la
foi chrétienne a contribué au
développement du canada me elle
également commis des erreurs
bon il ya eu appel je dirais général à
répondre aux recommandations de la
commission la vérité la réconciliation
il vous ici il appelait j'ai
l'impression les gouvernements à faire
la promotion de la culture autochtone
tous ses cd sont laissé des traces il
est revenu encore sur la mentalité
coloniale colonialiste qui a laissé ses
traces et puis par la suite banc et
s'est lancé dans une
son discours a plutôt porté sur
l'environnement la guerre dont il a
suivi le saluer le canada qui fait
preuve d' accueil auprès des réfugiés
il ya eu des messages politiques qui
sont passés danse dans ce discours là en
attendant qu'ils s'amènent vers son
véhicule
officiel pour par la suite bien sur les
plaines moi je vous ai fait l idée
générale de ce discours maintenant je
vais entendre les réactions et allait
vous permettrez les dames d'abord
bestial aux dates et prenez des notes et
je vous je vous ai sentis sursauter
parfois
c'est bien d'être franc
tout lance parallèle sur le tacle de
territoire la fleur de lys très peu mais
la feuille d'érable puis je pensais à
toutes les familles du nord qui est pas
du tout d'ablon parle des inuit et de
s'attacher à ce symbole mu et yamal
était
en se renseigner sur on est il pour des
causes causé des torts causés pour les
peuples autochtones pas sur l'histoire
du drapeau ça c'est moi la sepa réaction
c'est ce qu'on aime c'est ce qu'on veut
avoir je m'attendais à ce que il y avait
la gouverneure générale
inauka côté bruit avec des représentants
des différentes nations je m'attendais à
ce que ça soit ce qu'on entende les
temps qui ont été causés la volonté ou
la résilience et pourtant menés
rapidement la déclaration des nations
unies je pense la première fois qu'il en
parle j'ai peut-être manqué les au disco
et de sentir qu'ils commencent à nommer
des communautés religieuses au canada
qui ont commis aussi si ces pays ne
s'étendent pas juste les chrétiens
soient j'ai envie de l'avoir entendu où
il est vraiment temps tu
allais
s'explique parce que il ya publié il ya
quelques années de ça quelque chose qui
a fait beaucoup plaisir à des
scientifiques beaucoup plaisir a déjà
comme la varicelle et les autres crs à
l'environnement ya plus qu'une hausse
cliquer sur un gros document qui
s'appelle laudato ci et là dedans il
parle de l'écologie de l'environnement
et ça ratisse large évidemment de quand
on parle de ça c'est pas juste la
pollution de quelques compagnies c'est
notre manière de vivre et il parle de la
terre comme notre maison commune il fait
littéralement référence à 65 ans entre
lattes à 12 ses histoires de peut-être
plus malhabile de la feuille d'érable
peu de sirop d'érable puis on en mettant
un peu vrai qu'on a un peu derrière on
voyait madani qui veulent aller vers
l'écologie 20 la vie et il finit même à
marée par défaut défendent la vie
jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin jusqu'au bout à
la rend au roi pied in homme nommé marc
le d'être aussi sonné dans son sens le
dès le départ on sent que c'est ben beau
la feuille d'érable forêts puis ça
dégénère deux nuls et une calandre ça
dégénère a fini par parler de violence
tu as fini par nous parler de de ddd
génération du tort causé par le
gouvernement fédéral et des communautés
des chrétiens nombreux chrétiens qui ont
embarqué là-dedans curule rôle à jouer
ok en tout cas de la faire là et de fait
un moment donné il nous dit il faut ça
c'est peut-être la nouveauté d'un rien
tête c'est peut-être trop bémol il il
faut admettre nos fautes si on va aller
de l'avant le
ct ok allons-y on décrète
c'est pas venu à la est pas venu et
encore une fois il le dit par
le policier l'église qui en est
responsable
il a dit encore des communautés 6 c
'small qui vous manquent oui oui oui oui
pis je peux en être platon méchante mais
je sais que ça c'est important attendez
votre second louis alexandre drolet
faisait juste à côté du pape qui se
prépare à se déplacer vers la fine
bouche
on est à quelques mètres de lui à peine
vient tout juste de sortir de la
résidence de la gouverneure générale ici
il va entrer donc dans sa voiture il ya
eu des retards brunes ou en tout au long
de cette journée là il poursuit donc le
taux de pâques mobile du pape est prévue
dans une quinzaine de minutes à peine je
vous laisse voir donc le pape qui quitte
la citadelle en ce moment donc c'est
la sécurité qui l'entourent aura aussi
qui demeure encore très impressionnante
et je vous l'avais mentionné en début
d'émission c'est l'événement le plus
sécurisé de sa bise est ici au canada
alors le pape est en train d'entrer dans
son véhicule va quitter on nous a dit 10
à 15 minutes de repos avant de
finalement prendre ce bain de foule des
gens qui l'attend dans notamment sur la
grande allée alors
c'est bientôt fait il entrera il salue
les dignitaires je sais pas si vous
pouvez l'observer
il entrera dans son véhicule
prochainement mais vraiment ce qu'on se
dit c'est qu'on fait un petit 15 minutes
de repos et par la suite ben foule pour
le pape comme prévu peu partout dans la
ville de québec
merci alexandre puis ces images
l'olivier ensemble le en direct puis
vous voyez que la sécurité est
omniprésente dans le cas présent bon
salutations au pape françois voyer au
bas de l'écran là la couverture spéciale
va se poursuivre sur ici rdi nos au
texte également sont disponibles en
temps réel sur radio canada.ca barres
obliques que visitent pape je vous dis
tout ça parce que on doit saluer à ce
moment les gens de la première chaîne
mais pour la suite de cette couverture
là bas on vous convie à issy rdi on aura
également le passage du pape sur les
plaines à bord de la papemobile donc on
se retrouve dans quelques secondes